dogs Legion will see Assassin's Creed
Valhalla and some new announcements as
Ubisoft shows off the latest and
greatest just for you after that it's
gonna be Assassin's Creed Valhalla we're
taking an in-depth look in the post show
so be sure to stick around for it all
it's gonna be a fun day now if you see a
code on screen pop up go ahead and enter
that into you play on your PC for a
chance to win a free copy of Assassin's
Creed Odyssey Far Cry new dawn trials
rising or the division to and without
further ado it's time to introduce the
racers below we're getting warmed up
Belinda Garcia welcome to the show
excited to have you here a great time in
this warm up mode great time I mean were
you slightly sideways I mean that's a
good time
Fred Carmichael I know that you are
known to throw a flip or two it's not
going so good right now but uh yeah
we're making it down very slowly
well I'm sure Richard Sanford will be
happy to hear the slowly part of that
answer Richard wait hey hey yeah oh no
I'm super happy yeah you all take as
much time as you need
take it nice and slow I would love that
well this downhill route is definitely
oh trickier than it looks but
fortunately we're playing Time Attack
here this is the classic TrackMania mode
for anyone who's familiar you just get
you know we're in the on the track for
about three minutes and we and we get to
run it as many times as we can trying to
set the best time and trying to top
those leaderboards before it is through
oh it's dangerous though I feel like it
reaches the point where you just decide
to like throw the hammer down and like
yeah at this point control goes out the
window I'm just gonna try to careen down
as fast as I can I know we're really
close okay a little bit of smoother run
you know you know what they say slow is
smooth and smooth is fast
oh just got my fastest time no big deal
though
what was it 17 seconds oh man oh now I'm
feeling bad you didn't you didn't talk
to your car enough now you're right yeah
you know I shouldn't meditated yeah
commune with the vehicle as you like
connecting on a spiritual level with
your with your car you want I heard that
from some like other drivers you know
it's best if you kind of really get to
learn more about your car but that just
seemed to be working
maybe seconds 17 seconds all you
improved your time a little bit rich
Belinda you're nipping at my heels here
I this is this is good competition I
like this folks I like this okay I can I
can keep it in control but then I'm
going a little too slow and then I start
going fast oh man someone's oh man yeah
this is now do I have one last 12 second
run here let's go be able into literally
upside down the same spot I don't know
how Oh Fred takes the time attack nicely
done nicely done
alright now we're gonna mix it up and
we're gonna check out some rounds let's
get into that now rounds is where you
race the same track everyone starts at
the beginning at the same time and
finishes you don't get to like loop it
it's one run and then you get points
based on your placement and then after a
few rounds I think we've got three four
track here whoever's the point winner
wins oh gosh the trees are much more
dangerous in this map no don't treat no
okay don't treat Melinda you were zoom
in though I was zoom in the trees to cut
through the dirt yeah I feel like
trackmania if you're gonna take a
shortcut you better be airborne or
something yeah otherwise you're
scrubbing speed off badly man I'm
consistently fast as long as the track
is just going in a straight line yeah
which works not really the track baby
that mantle is all yours for it see I
make them figuring out what happened
previous round I talk to my car about
going fast and not necessarily managing
the a bump
now you know the cars just like oh we
want to go fast down and I'm like yeah
yeah you gotta go fast rich is out to a
commanding lead a lot of points with
that one is that you are losing it's
like one false move off all right Fred I
see what do we got rich up top with the
26 Oh Fred in second with 19 then it's
me and then Belinda and shout out to
Andy who's in our spectator seat he's
showing you the action and we're gonna
switch it up now and get on to another
match here another rounds [ __ ] coming
for you now it's time to tangle with a
little bit of those more not enough
challenging the right word but
kind of mix it up elements of TrackMania
such as right from the start we good
it's crazy I mean I started too high on
the wall okay
recovered that was a pretty slick
actually bounced off the wall I mean
this is turn right to go left to right
I don't like that at all
it's like unmanageable Fred out to the
early lead yeah I'm gonna need you to
hit one of those pillars no problem no
problem happy to it very considerate of
you Fred all right you can tell them
when I'm making not a great maneuver by
when my voice yeah they think it's that
thing we're like if you end up who look
you want to look at them so that you
know where they are and can avoid them
but if you look too long you end up
focusing on them and then it draws you
in X early in appreciate all right well
as Belinda and I battle it out for third
it's Fred and Richard at the top oh no I
didn't start at the top battling for
that top spot here in our second rounds
competition he's been obviously the
stakes are high
I'm a damn innovative might be all over
what's happening no no I do not have to
choose to make it across this terrain
the previous one - me - yeah alright
let's go to our third and final map here
and settle who the real champion is it's
gonna be Richard
alright well we're coming into the final
rounds match now the final track Fred
you have been a contender for the number
one spot here but so far Richards been
getting the best of you what's your
approach to this track he's he's fast
but not fast enough I got this one this
one's kind of tricky so I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty confident feeling good you
feeling spry yeah I'm good I'm good I
like it Belinda I think you're out in
front of me could you please like not
we're all pretty close little bumps big
bumps it's in this track are very hard
to maneuver over oh yeah
this raised it's like it's banked if you
hit it from one direction but then if
you go over the hump it's gonna be in be
a little trouble oh ok just gotta really
keep it keep it going all right Christy
Linda I'm gonna need you both to beat
Fred please
oh you're gonna recruit us his gamertag
is you be rich is that a promise if we
comply you will be rich be rich in
satisfaction that richard won again yes
come on T let's take a number one spot
at least once during this take a dang
broadcast up there these points are
adding up that was a big bite rich down
a third mm-hmm
here we go this is gonna settle it
taking the scenic route take art I think
our viewers on a lovely journey here oh
gosh about those hiccups she's scared to
go off the track I don't know he has
avoided fearless yeah that's pretty much
it
okay I mess up right there every single
getting quiet cuz I really want to get a
first-place finish on at least one of
these I messed up again I don't reckon
there you be rich wins a match GG
alright folks that's gonna bring our
little let's play kind of competitive
segment here to an end I want to thank
you all for parts
bading Belinda nice work out there I
tried that's right I just love the
scenery I was just taking my time
listen it's fun to get out there in a
fast car and just do some things only
Fred Carmichael close but no cigar this
time around are you plotting your
revenge already I'll get him next time
Richard is there gonna be a next time or
you're just going off into the sunset
with this w I mean I'm definitely
driving off into the sunset but even if
there is a next time I don't think he's
gonna be painting and thus a rivalry is
born or maybe continued yeah yeah thank
you all for joining so much folks coming
up next we're gonna be taking an
in-depth look at the map editor and some
of the creation tools in TrackMania but
first let's do a little schedule
check-in after our TrackMania segment
here it's going to be the ubisoft
forward pre-show at 11:30 a.m. Pacific
time where we'll be seeing some AI
teammates come into Ghost Recon
breakpoint getting an update from the
crew to trials rising we'll be showing
off a fan favorite and we'll see a whole
bunch more games on display then at noon
pacific time when that timer runs out
it's gonna be ubisoft forward the main
showcase watchdogs legion Assassin's
Creed Valhalla some new announcements
and more don't want to miss that one and
after it's over stick around for an
in-depth look at Assassin's Creed
Valhalla that's all coming up here
shortly but now I've got August in
divita producer at Ubisoft naday Oh the
creators of TrackMania joining me to
talk about creation in TrackMania
I understand welcome ed Oh Chris Tsar
Peter via oh man exciting times for you
you know your game has just launched
people are out there racing in droves
how does it feel it's great it's really
really good it's really an evolution of
track mignon
we could not wait for it and also folks
are out there creating stuff we see
right here we're seeing some map
creation sped up we got a little time
lapse thing pre-prepared for us here as
we talk through the map creation mode
but I guess give us like an overview
starting off August an like what's your
what was your team's goal when like
putting these creative tools in the
hands of
so we always want to the tools to be
easy to handle and the big issue we were
facing that there's too many blocks in
the game there is 1600 blocks is a game
actually and so we had to organize all
the tools and to organize the new
features and he's doing a great job
right now because he knows what he's
doing but when you start making the
first map you really don't know what
where you're going to it's really hard
to get to yeah
sorry to interrupt but when you say
blocks you just mean all these little
pieces that we're seeing of track yeah I
did this way that way this terrain
that's right yeah that's how you walk so
if we if we if we piece of the map is
what we call a block so it's it's some
size you have words you have decoration
you have check points boosters and all
of this makes a map so there's so many
bugs and there's also trees as I know
from personal experience
pretty cute kids again so we're seeing
here some they are not the players not
just sort of creating the map they're
also like okay I add it a little bit now
I'm testing a little bit now I'm adding
a little bit that testing is kind of
like the immediate feedback on you know
is this working is it not as is the feel
I like is it not yeah you always have to
taste what you're doing just to see if
the curve is right if the speed is right
and we added some some tools for that so
for example when you test and then you
come back to the game
you have your gust to see what was your
speed at at this time and and you know
to try to reproduce or to do better than
him so you can try every part of the
game and get pretty good in good but for
the videos interesting okay so when
you're when you're starting out you know
obviously we're seeing someone with some
map creation skills but when players are
starting out you know is are there some
some tools to help them out there is it
pretty you know are you what do you
recommend in terms of like okay when
you're starting out just try to make
like
a simple shape or you know try to just
put in a sec jump and that's that's good
yeah well the free version of track
manga is what we call a simple editor so
there is a simple little advanced editor
what we're seeing now is the advanced
editor so with all the tools all the
blocks and the simple is Ito is it deter
is like a based off of blocks so the
blocks you need to do like a super track
but a good one you can at least make a
good one and I recommend to start with
this and then after you can get to the
city to make crazy stuff like he's doing
right now nice now is that advanced
editor pretty akin to what the
TrackMania team uses to create the
actual tracks in the game we are using
everyday to make the track we ever eat
will be Burton's again we give it to the
player as well so they can make the same
track as us nice so you can challenge
people to beat you at your own game a
little bit to track that amazes I played
some tracks that always because it was
so great well that's when you hire them
for the team right well the video right
now is used to be a player on still the
player now he's working with us and we
always have like pro players coming into
the team that's very cool so I mean
we're talking to hear about the
TrackMania community then you know
they're people out there gonna be
creating these tracks if they they're
creating the tracks they want people to
race on them how are they gonna how do
they get folks in the seats you know to
race on their track it's really simple
with the next track man yup because no
aren't you done with your track you can
just put it out there on what we call a
server give you a preview server and
they can like everybody can come up and
test your tracks they can write your
tracks and when they rate it they give
it four is about five stars afterwards
if your track is good for the players
and we decide it's good
we're going to edit that what we call
track of the day which is like the front
page of the game and everyone is going
to play it for sure every day's a new
track made by the players nice and so
there's also but there is also that like
server where and can any player just
kind of go in and be like let me see
what new creations people have today and
then rate them so if that's your if
that's your thing if you're looking
maybe for inspiration or just looking to
try some wacky new tracks that's nobody
is like pushing about right now so it's
always push today so you can say is
always talks to taste on new tracks to
taste it's really great nice and so if
you get that so you get your track in
there you get enough get enough stars
get considered by the team and you
select them as a track of the day then
you know people are racing it and
there's some incentives for people to
get on that track as well right yes what
we call a competition you track at 7:00
p.m. CST and the this competition
rewards with what we call trophies and
worse trophies gives you like a rank in
the global ranking track man yeah so
every day you have to come if you want
to to come to compete on this track and
then you thanks and speaking of
competition we are going to be seeing
some of the top community racers take on
this very track here in just a few
moments folks in our next segment right
now we're talking with Augustine about
creation in TrackMania and so far we
focused on the the map editor the track
creator that we're seeing in kind of a
time-lapse fast-forward here but there's
also other creative outlets I mean you
can customize for example the delivery
on your car yeah you was because Quinta
so you can create any skin you want with
what we call the skin painter and you
can say it really easily with the world
within clips in just one click you can
find new new skins that you like and you
can you can apply them or add them to
the
it's it's really changing changing game
for TrackMania is so easier to ski and
discover new skins what's your what's
your approach here I'll just and do you
like pick one you like and stick with it
for months or you like switching it up
every other day mixing I just go to the
least and I have my skins again
excellent yeah it's so fun to see the
what people come up with and I imagine
this is also something for you you know
these are the creation tools you use
your team is used to create the tracks
the skins etc but you know to a certain
extent you give the tools to the players
they're gonna come back and surprise you
yes they're always like surprising us we
feel really great new new invention I
mean they can create both as well game
mode so they're going to create new
things every day and every day it's it's
glowing yes and one of the things that I
have really enjoyed you know even when
not playing TrackMania is seeing some of
the like highlight reels people put
together because as we'll see a little
bit later on and as you folks who no
trackmania know very well TrackMania
tracks can get pretty wild and the the
kind of precision the that's that like
just like excellent slicked like drift
precision that people can display looks
really cool and you have some in-game
tools to help people showcase that stuff
yeah every track you can you can save
your replay and then you can use it to
make your own videos so these two DS the
tool is as well as the tools that we're
using to make trailers and at the same
time players can make their trailers
like a wave what we call one key project
and it's really good to see what I can
do with that because I can change the
light I can change the skins I can
change the color ii display text it's
really great
well there we have our completed track
don't forget to save your tracks when
you're creating them folks and we'll be
there's an autosave excellent I
understand you put a lot of people's
hearts too uh daddy's just 10 we'll be
taking a look
at that track in action in just a few
moments here but August and before I let
you go we I wanted to touch base on just
kind of again that community aspect of
you know how do people find these
creations what's a great weight like
that there's the club system that sort
of allows people to connect to different
different clubs of friends or maybe this
club focuses on certain types of races
and etc etc just give us an idea of how
people are going to share these
creations and discover in people's
creations yes so it's what we call clubs
and you can create objects you want
private to big with friends for example
or just the streaming community within a
club and we think those clubs you can
share screens you can share bars you can
create what we call a campaign which is
the same tool we're using to create our
own campaigns with 25 laps and you can
create also events so people can gather
around and use the same skin for example
I've flipped tag and compete within each
other on either worlds and share
everything I can they can also share
videos for example it's really great
well it sounds like there's lots of
tools for folks to get creative to share
those creations to discover new stuff in
addition to just racing and trying to
beat the tires off of each other yeah
excellent
Augustine thank you so much for joining
us a talk a little bit more about
TrackMania folks remember TrackMania is
available now download and play for free
on the epic game store and on you play
I'll do send thank you for joining us
and Congrats
yeah affect you it's been great all
right folks we've got some competitive
play coming up here just shortly but
first another schedule reminder of the
order event events today our TrackMania
showcase continues until about 11:30
Pacific time then it's the ubisoft
forward pre-show we'll be taking a look
at AI teammates in Ghost Recon
breakpoint getting updates for the crew
to hearing from trials rising about a
special new track for fans who like long
rides and a bunch more then at noon
pacific time it's the main event ubisoft
forward with watchdogs Legion Assassin's
Creed Valhalla and more from Ubisoft
upcoming lineup of games stick around
immediately following the show for a
deeper look at Assassin's Creed Valhalla
and
now it's back to the track joining me
now is Omar Ben Abdullah live producer
at Ubisoft Nanao to talk about all the
ways in her TrackMania can get a little
more competitive
Omar how's it going man pretty good and
you how you doing I'm doing good I'm
excited to see some of the some skills I
mean not they're not that we had no
skills early this is a whole different
level right because these are some of
the top racers in the community yeah
what we did basically invites the six or
seven I think best players of the closed
alpha we organized and we'll be using
them racing in Rowan's mode so they all
start at the same time and the fastest
guy win
all right who's your money on here at
the at the outset uh I'll just take the
ECP can go with shorty since he won that
round Bob's right there yeah and keen
eyed viewers will note this is the track
we just saw being created and actually
the place player I think in that round
is the one who made it so Tona yeah you
can step it up as well we can we nuts
East went around I believe it I believe
it so as we watch them compete I wanted
to talk to you a little bit more about
you know how people kind of like take on
new competitive challenges in TrackMania
because you know right from the get-go
you start playing
there's the inherent competition of
racing you're trying to get a better
medal a faster time and you're maybe
you're racing against your friends but
what are some of the other ways people
can kind of get into that broader
competitive scene basically what we try
to do is to design features that will be
good for any kind of level you are you
have on TrackMania whether you're a
professional player or just someone that
wants to discover the game and get
better in two days so you have a lot of
new ways to train and get better at the
game gaining more medals maybe reaching
the gold medals on all the maps of the
official campaign which is a great
achievement already you'll be able to
play against VIPs ghosts which means
that you'll be able to compete against
yourself or against your favorite
streamer against your friends so I'm
quite a lot of possibility to you to get
better attract many nice side
like the streamer touch because then you
know your if you're watching them in the
chat say like you can kind of see what
web they've laid down the time and then
go take you out to the track and see a
stack up like that's a feature we love
at the studio because you can compare
yourself against someone you would love
to play against and maybe beat him and
be happy with that
excellent shout out to Tony who did take
that second win on the track yeah of his
own creation nicely done
so Ron threw a new track here and OH see
that's the kind of move that yeah what
I'm trying to get used to you used those
news I was reading yeah and so these
folks have been have played a little bit
already but in terms of what they're
seeing what competitive players are
seeing in TrackMania what's kind of some
stuff that's gonna be a little bit oh my
goodness no wonder they're sending it no
wonder yeah you know in terms of like
okay so so you've you've done you're
sort of like you've done your solo
competition you want to like maybe
compete with players on a broader scale
seek out folks who race around the same
time as you like what's it what's there
what are some good ways to do that well
well we have currently on the game will
be daily cups which is something
completely new for TrackMania well
you'll be able to compete against every
player in the world which wants to
participate every day at 7 p.m.
european time and basically you'll be
able to see how good you are on the
track of the day and and compete against
everyone in the world and see how good
you are against each other then
obviously you have the Nations League
which will happen each week well you'll
be able to represent your country and
and see how which country is the best
basically each week on the game and then
the open ground League which is a great
way to feel the pressure of the personal
players because you'll be playing on the
same maps and the same format as the
Grand League so you'll be basically
leaving the experience of a professional
player by playing the grand league and
maybe if you get good maybe at some
point role you'll be training the ground
league and play against the six best
players in the world oh my goodness well
we see grandly
plastered all over this track here
that's is that what that's the sort of
highest level of TrackMania eSport it is
basically what we have on the ground
link is the 16 best players in the world
we cannot have anyone better than them
and we just put them on a special format
that we design well everything is
possible until the end and the last
second of the last track so it's really
great to see and we are excited for for
the next season which will start on
September nice so in September more
grandly action coming your way but you
know there's a lot of competitive space
in between the tippy tip top for you to
get involved and is that something that
you know in terms of like I just booted
up TrackMania I've raced a little bit is
that gonna be easy for players to find
what's the way to get into that yeah
you'll have in an in-game menu which is
cool events and basically you'll be able
to check out the events you'll have you
want to play maybe during the week and
it will be also easy for the people to
create events through the clubs well
you'll basically be able to create an
event in less than two minutes and and
decide which map you want to have which
kind of format so we made everything
easier for everyone on TrackMania nice
so that I mean that can even be just you
creating the events to just play with
your friends or also classmates or
whatever else yeah nice and so that's so
these clubs this is kind of a way like
clubs are also a way that people can get
into you know finding people who you
know like to race the same time again or
you know our friends are connected
through different ways and the clubs can
be kind of any size right yeah you can
have a clip which is completely private
and where you play only with your
friends or your roommates classmates or
you can just have a public club which is
available enjoyable by everyone and and
just have fun with a lot of people doing
a lot of events and and organizing a lot
of content and maybe just a club that
focuses on huge jumps like the one we do
there yeah only gem snaps and yeah that
will be quite great I would say this is
a pretty close match
yeah leader only has a few points ahead
so I like it thanks for recruiting these
folks into into the action here to give
us a look at some real some real speedy
real tight turns you can see how good
they are by their drifts and how well
they know their Maps obviously since
they've been playing the the all-star
for I think a bit more than 2 2 or 3
months now so they're getting used to
the game and yeah dumpling really good
compare hi wait for you I wish I had
watched them play before our session
earlier that's all right for the future
to learn them up actually that's true
although you know can you really learn
from a ghost if it just screams out
ahead of you so fast yeah yeah work my
way up yeah so these community events
this kind of uh
this stuff that is organized through
clubs as like so it's organized through
clubs which is kind of organic and
players all around the world can make
that happen but you at Madeo are also
sort of curating stuff and experiences
and events for players to get into yeah
what we try to do is to have a mix of
community event well basically we have
players organizing event that's
something that is there for more than 14
years now on TrackMania so so we love to
see that we love to see community
creating content on our game we also
organize ourselves our events through
grandly to daily caps donations League
and things like that so it's kind of a
mix of trying to get content for every
kind of players and also a way to be
able to create content and events
whether you're a great player just want
to have fun with your friends nice Wow
that's the time separating the top yeah
it's really good
and that's pretty fast is very very
tight here as we move on to I believe
our fourth and final map of this
competitive section and it's still
really close all right folks it's down
to the wire
Omar still believing in your racer
shorty out there I think you suppose so
yeah that race yeah and that's a great
map everything can happen there so
might be someone to all taking story do
you like like that kind of map where it
I mean it's exciting right cuz like
dramatic stuff can happen but also it's
a little scary like you can just fly off
the track in like la well you can go
from first to last basically by doing
one mistake and one short mistake so
that's pretty exciting for this big that
does it's not that fun for the players
obviously don't lose everything on one
time but yeah that's how you handle
pressure on TrackMania yeah you know at
some point like fun becomes like oh it's
the thrill you know you're risking a lot
more for the bigger payoff yeah right
yeah what do you call this kind of road
surface here that's it's like a hill in
the middle I was trying to figure this
out earlier actually we do have a name
but I don't like to use it I just let
people call it as they wants I'm cooling
it's a different way in French obviously
oh sure sure course yeah basically
everyone can can name the world as they
want and there's many ways to say it
like select the road we are seeing right
now the language of racing yeah it takes
many forms yeah
alright so we're watching the
competition play out here once people
you know TrackMania is out now free to
download and play what would you
recommend in terms of like okay I just
want to get into the into the
competition against other folks I want
to challenge myself right out of the
gate what's the best way to get that
started to be quite honest the best
thing will be to play the daily cab
because we'll be facing players from all
around the world on the track that is
known only each day so the track of the
day map so you'll be able to see how
good you are against other people and
and you can do that every day so you can
maybe see your progression on the whole
week and maybe at the end of the week
you'll you'll be able to be people that
you wouldn't even think about on the
elite state of the week I like that I
like that kind of like because you know
a lot about kind of competition is that
progression and you know the sense of
moving up in the rankings but also of oh
like
this person is always the one who I see
a few places ahead of me like you're
chasing them you wanna you want to track
them down now this is our last this is
our last race is that right yeah last
round and saw these seconds so the
pressure is on they're coming around
these he's like slot like ah but he's in
there yeah yep coming up around this big
it's like s turn you still thought I
mean even him he can feel you can feel
the positive vibes coming from you
Fennell so to what and he's anything
felt great there he goes back to the
right racer shorty coming in with a
victory and Omar thank you so much for
talking about competitive TrackMania
anything else you want to mention before
we wrap it up well obviously thank you
for having me and thanks to the playoffs
ah playing this convention thanks to all
the closed alpha players we had because
they helped us truly to make this game
better and we're pretty happy with it
with the truck many we have right now so
yeah just play trackmania it's free and
have fun on it I'm pretty sure we all
have and yep that's it all right
Omar thank you so much TrackMania folks
it's out now on epic game store end you
play go ahead and download it get in
there and get racing now our time with
TrackMania is coming to a close and it's
on to the next show Ubisoft forward
pre-show is starting momentarily we're
gonna take a look at Ghost Recon
breakpoint the crew 2 trials rising new
stuff coming from all these games you're
not gonna want to miss it and then when
the countdown timer hits zero its
Ubisoft forward the big showcase of the
latest and greatest upcoming games from
Ubisoft followed by an in-depth look at
Assassin's Creed Valhalla we got a lot
more in store for you so let's go ahead
and throw it over to Kat
thank you Chris and hello everyone and
welcome to the Ubisoft Ford pre-show the
main event will be starting in just 30
minutes and will feature news from our
unreleased games including watchdogs
Legion Assassin's Creed Valhalla hyper
scape and more now to warm up we have 30
minutes of the days from the games
you're already paying like ghostfreak on
breakpoint trials rising and dirty - as
well as some exclusive behind-the-scenes
so you can get to know us a little
better so let's see stop this ratio
within a date from just days 20 20
if your resistance pan is more to win
some cool swag head over to the jazz
dance website for all the details for
our in this segment we have something a
little different than what we usually do
a few years ago you bizarre created the
Ubisoft entrepreneurs lab in the open
innovation accelerator this allowed us
to create partnerships and synergies
with indie Studios from across the
industry and since so many industry
events were canceled this year we wanted
to showcase several indie projects and
teams that Ubisoft has been
collaborating with over the past few
years our first indie Showcase is
developer machine and Mensch who is
working on the curious expedition to
distill more from the team beyond the
game hi my name is Masha and I'm a game
designer at machine mesh machine
mensches the smaller diverse indie game
studio with eight wonderful employees
based here in Berlin our connection with
here Asaf came through a program
dedicated to create ever-growing
relationships with independent
developers to talk about and share his
parties and knowledge we work together a
mutual respect which we much appreciated
we're working on the qs expedition tool
which is the secret to our expedition
simulation game this time the game is
set in Paris in 1899 during the World
Expo when the Eiffel Tower was built but
more importantly you will be traveling
to these mysterious Islands you will be
interacting with unknown tribes fight
dangerous beasts find many secrets
thanks to a procedure technology every
time you play it's a new world new
characters at the new storyline that you
shape with each of your interactions
until it becomes really your own unique
adventure
and we will have more indie guests
coming up later in the pre-show so stick
around now a while ago you've a soft
release it's very first live-action TV
show on Apple TV plus and it's a comedy
about making video games called mythic
quest Ravens banquet and to keep the
show authentic Ubisoft's redstone studio
went above and beyond by creating a
playable sandbox for the game that is
actually featured in the show so now
let's head behind the scenes for an
exclusive look okay it's very classy ask
all right now I'm starting to understand
I to keep all my awards at the front of
my office it's entirely empty so mythic
quest is Ubisoft's first live-action
comedy the whole show is about a team
that is developing a super successful
MMORPG and it's about you know all the
all the people within the game
development team and their relationships
and what they go through and creating
one of the world's most successful games
alright incredible thank you but are we
sure that we're finished when we heard
about what was going on we weren't
really sure if we were a great fit
because we always made shooters and
realistic and we listened to the pitch
and we were super excited about the idea
so we thought all right what's what does
Ubisoft have that we could channel to
fit this you [ __ ] me yes you're
[ __ ] me but I'm not enjoying it it's
for the game we started on the project I
think we imagined me would just make
video clips that would run on screens in
the background or something so it would
feel like a real game studio though once
we saw the script once we started
collaborating with the team we realized
oh they want a game like an actual game
of course making an actual game would
take years so we started selecting the
pieces that they really needed for
certain scenes and from there was not
long before we said you know what if we
make this actually play it wonderfully
you make it so you can connect a
controller
and that's what we ended up doing we had
requests to do things like makin tages
viral disease in which people bleed out
of their eyeballs first then they bleed
out of their anus and they vomit and
bleed all their heinous at the same time
we set it up in such a way that you
could trigger it in stages because we
didn't know what the timing was gonna be
the idea here is we can hit it and I can
control the timing of when things are
happening so the next time you hit it he
starts puking out blood and at this
point we would probably have the camera
start panning back like this and then
you can hit the button again and you see
the blood ocean itself is started coming
in and so now they're all bleeding out
of the back end as well and then the
final is just everybody exploding in
bloody gore and then this is Keith's
idea anyone of this goals coming up and
bobbing up and down in water so can we
actually make this quick I've got a lot
of work to do is dripping blood ocean
out of everything yeah yeah releasing a
disease in the game right before a
global pandemic was not a great look
today was the first time we showed
mythic quest Ravens Bank between
audience I've never seen it with more
than six or seven people in a room and
so I wanted to make sure that we gave
them an opportunity to hopefully
recognize that this is a giant love
letter to them to the industry itself
I was a little nervous I gotta be honest
I thought it was gonna be a little
fringy but it was fantastic I thought
there was a lot of truth and in the
humor it's about time that we had a show
about our industry you could tell when
the audience was laughing when they
really hit something that that felt like
the game industry I think it's brilliant
alright so if you have not yet seen it
the first season of mystic quest Ravens
banquet is available right now on Apple
TV plus and a full version of this
making on will be coming out over the
next few days all right now it is time
to fasten your seat belts and start your
engines as we head out to Lyon France to
visit our team at ubisoft ivory tower to
get an update on the crew to
hi everyone and welcome to the crew 2 at
Ubisoft for word my name is James Reese
I'm a community developer here at ivory
tower and I'll be your host for this
quick glimpse into all the exciting
things we have going on over the next
few weeks it's been two years already
since launch with six major updates and
hundreds of vehicles under our belt and
our latest update summer in Hollywood
only went live a few days ago let's have
a look
we can't wait for you to get your hands
on what's coming there have been a few
speed bumps along the way
but over the past two years you the
community have made the crew to a
motorsports playground where all players
are welcome and where anything is
possible so thank you to the crew social
exchange discord Reddit and all of our
players we've got a little something for
you in game to show our appreciation
it's the 67 Volkswagen Beetle so let's
see what kind of Hollywood twist you can
put on it that's it from me there'll be
more news dropping over summer so keep
your eyes peeled
starting with this
in case you missed it make sure to build
up the game right now to unlock the
amazing 69 Volkswagen Beetle that was
just shown in the video
and stay tuned in the near future for
more info about here three of the crew
to our next video is from our second
indie guest Bossa studios who will be
injecting a delirious dose of fun with
surgeon simulator to enjoy hi I'm Nick
from bosses studios and on the senior
game designer on the upcoming surgeon
simulator to that fall so we're always
keen to share game development knowledge
and Ubisoft has been a fantastic partner
in this they deliver lectures on
procedural content development and play
a science and in turn we shared with
them the ideation processes that we use
to develop initial ideas into living
breathing games which brings me on to
surgeon simulator 2 we've really doubled
down on the physics base pandemonium
that the series is notorious for and
we've pretty much expanded on every
other aspect of the game as well so this
time around you'll no longer just a
floating and combined to the operating
table
you're actually a full first-person
surgeon with the entire medical facility
to explore and in addition for the
levels that you'll find in story mode
you'll now be able to create your own
unique levels and experiences using
Bossa labs creation mode it's really
easy to use intuitive set of tools that
allow us players to create either on
their own or an online multiplayer with
up to three friends everything plays
create can then be uploaded and shared
with the community and here surgery
really is just the tip of the iceberg
during our close out the period we've
seen players create all sorts of amazing
stuff from bowling alleys to space
stations pirate ships to horror themed
escape rooms and this is before the game
is even released so we absolutely cannot
wait to see what players create when we
launch the game that's coming August and
in fact if you preorder surgeon
simulator 2 you can receive exclusive
closed buta access so for those of you
who are just joining us you're watching
the pre-show and Ubisoft forward will
start once the countdown on your screen
reaches 0 and make sure you log into you
play to unlock rewards as you watch the
main event but now our next segment is
about an easter egg in the division 2 so
let's go behind the scenes with the devs
from Ubisoft massive studio in Malmo
Sweden to find out more running through
collapsed buildings climbing over fallen
debris and encountering makeshift living
spaces is common for players of the
division - within its post pandemic
environment many players have spotted
something a bit more unusual which has
left them asking what's up with all
these rubber ducks
so there's a thing in in programming
especially where you talk to a rubber
duck and it's a way to solve your
problems if you talk to a rubber duck
and just say things out loud it helps
one of our artists decided to take this
to another level when he used the rubber
duck scaled up so like a ginormous scale
I put it in the level just to remind him
to do something and it sat there for a
while and the rest of us kind of really
loved this giant rubber duck sitting
there for so long we decided to put a
little memorials
to it cross the world what started off
as little memorials and then we started
adding stories to them so there's one
where these two Ducks are sitting on a
bench having a date together there's
another one somewhere we're sitting with
an umbrella hiding from the rain the
idea of the Ducks is similar to the rest
of our storytelling where we're trying
to add some hope into the world because
you're coming in as a division agent to
try and save what you can and rebuild
but you need to know there's something
there to save
so having bits of happiness lets you
know like it's still worth saving for
these little happy moments one shrine in
particular became a beloved fan favorite
showing up multiple times across YouTube
and read it so Karen how was your day
well Luke it's been productive so the
origin story of productive one of our
level designers they did an amazing pond
one day and we decided to make cougar
Fiji out of it and put it in the game
and it became like a duck shrine and I
started finding it and wondering where
it came from
we've been finding these rubber duckies
all over the map it says here on the
wall in graffiti productive and there's
a large rubber ducky bigger than all the
other ones we found and he's he's got
bottles of booze all around him not only
that but he has a couple soldier duckies
guarding a parrot in a cage but there's
there's more just like this in the
vision too
what's really great about our community
is they come together they find a common
thing that they want to develop or find
or get unlocked and they just put time
and effort into it we don't put them in
easy to find places so that means
players are genuinely hopefully enjoying
just exploring the environment and
finding all those little easter eggs
we've hidden around and also not the
easter eggs just the main part of the
game and all the storytelling we put
into it haven't found all of them I
don't know exactly how many there are
but they haven't found all of the Ducks
you encouraged by the community's
response to the Ducks developers
recently hid another secret in the game
and made it the focal point of an
all-new community challenge we actually
put Tommy the teddy bear into the game
well Tommy the teddy bear is a trauma
Teddy mentioned in a lot of lore but the
bear itself actually was not in the game
with episode three we put a bunch of
them into the world
actually opened up Easter egg hunt for
him specifically it's a nice little
exciting moment when you've kind of open
read it and you see someone's found the
thing that you kind of just snuck in
under the radar and no one really knows
about it and it so the players are
really clever
there's some hard Easter eggs that some
of the level designers and gameplay
designers have put in and people who -
to solve it with no help whatsoever game
is a smart so now that you know be on
the lookout for both the Ducks and teddy
bears
next time you boot up the division chief
we now have our final indie guests
Thunder Lotus games who were the 2017
winner of the indie series that took
place in Montreux so let's find out more
about the beautiful coziness of spirit
fare in this next video everybody I'm
Rodrigue market here at Thunder Lotus
we're an indie studio based out of
Montreal Canada and makers of the games
jodan sundered and our new game spirit
fair which is due out later this year
for the past six years we've tried to
make triple equality games with a
hand-drawn indie heart hitting a quality
standard consistently in game dev is a
huge challenge there's so much trial and
error on the path and during the
sundered production we were lucky enough
to have the Ubisoft entrepreneurs
program in our corner to help us reach
our goals as co-winners of the Ubisoft
indie series in 2017 we receive not only
generous funding but also crucial
mentorship and access to the use of
testing facilities so we're grateful to
Ubisoft for their support and helping us
make what we become our biggest success
to date we've taken that experience with
us on to what is our most ambitious
production yet and that spirit fair
which we're calling a cosy management
game about dying in spirit fair you play
still as a newly appointed very master
to the deceased Anna Stella you're gonna
build a boat you're gonna explore the
world in search of spirit passengers
seeking passage to the afterlife you're
gonna spend relaxing quality time with
them you're gonna create lasting
memories but ultimately you're gonna
have to learn how to say goodbye to your
cherished friends
it's a game that's near and dear to our
hearts and something really special we
can't wait to share it with the world
later this year so look for it soon on
PC on Xbox one kiss for a Nintendo
switch and Xbox game pass thanks a lot
and Cheers it is time for an update on
our favorite motorcycle platformer with
the insanity pain and triumph we all
know and we all love trials rising came
out last year but I think the team from
our red link studio in Helsinki has a
little surprise coming to the game for
the fans of the franchise so let's take
a look
hi we're here today to introduce you to
an exciting new endurance challenge
coming to trial freising but to make
sure that we respect social distancing
guidelines on TN i decided okay ladies
and gentlemen welcome back to the giga
track
far from a remake of the classic track
from Charles evolution this is an
all-new journey across the world of
Charles rising and by far the longest
track that we've ever put in a trout by
far the longest track we've ever put in
a trials game the Giga track will take
you across many different environments
from the iconic maybe you want to tell
them [ __ ] rack is like life it starts
and it ends and it's long depends how
you enter it and also one secret thing
for else transferred to one
prepare for the ultimate test of trials
endurance yoga track releases miss
Thursday July 16th for the low low price
you heard that right rider's Giga track
will be available for free to all trials
rising players when it releases this
Thursday
you heard that right the giggle track is
coming to the game and it will be the
longest most insane
track in trials history and it will be
free for all trials rising players now
for our last game update the Ghost Recon
break one team is ready to share some
details on their upcoming updates AI
teammates are coming to the game let's
have a look at the trailer the time has
come
ai teammates are back in Ghost Recon
break point and for all solo players
there gonna be a game changer available
at any point after you have reached
erawan for the first time Fury
fix-it and Vasily can be activated or
dismissed at will and from the beginning
you will be able to fully customise them
this customization includes all of the
physical attributes as well as gear
equipment or even full costumes your
teammates can be tweaked just as much as
your main character just like nomads
your teammates will adapt and reacts to
the world of Aurora and its environments
and they will always follow your own
behavior if you decide to go stealth
they will equip silencers and Crouch or
go prone when possible but if you decide
to go loud an open fire they will stick
by your side when deployed you can issue
different orders to your teammates
through the order wheel there are four
different orders you can give to your
teammates you can tell them to regroup
on your location to hold their current
position to go to a specific location
and to open fire on nearby enemies these
orders can be given at any time even
through your binoculars and drone once
they approach potential threats the
teammates will notify you and mark them
automatically with a good look at your
enemies you will be able to set up a
sync shot where each of your teammates
picks a target you can even link it to
your three sync shot drones for
simultaneous seven target takedown the
teammates have weapons equipped at all
times
a versatile assault rifle to accommodate
all situations and a primary weapon that
you will be able to find - indeed apart
from mark upgrades and passive bonuses
the full gunsmith is accessible to your
teammates and their weapon of choice
will have a direct effect on the
battleground depending on the type of
weapon may have equipped the teammates
will adapt their engagement distance and
rate of fire from close distance shotgun
wielding all the way to long distance
sniper shots of course if you get taken
down your teammates priority will be to
try and rescue you to achieve that it
will first focus their fire on the
surrounding enemies before getting to
you and they will expect the same from
you especially as you will be able to
carry them to safety if the situation
requires it finally the teammates will
also be your best allies in any vehicle
especially on the road and during high
stake pursuits the teammates will be
available for all solo Ghost Recon
breakpoint players on July 15th and we
cannot wait to see your reactions we'll
see you on the battlefield ghosts
hey ghosts I'm grace from the ghost
recon team as you've just seen the AI
teammates are finally landing in Ghost
Recon break point with our next major
update on July 15th alongside the AI
teammates this update comes with a ton
of new content including a gunsmith
upgrade new PvP content quality of life
updates and more you will be able to try
it all during our next free weekend from
July 16th to July 20th but that's not
all we've got one last thing to show you
enjoy and we'll see you in a row ghosts
we stand against sentinels illegal
occupation join us
separated sentinel wins but united we
cannot
and now our very final video for this
pre-show is another episode of our wild
moments compiling the craziest and
coolest place from you our players
let's go interrogate him
so there's a line that people want me to
yell but I can't usually do it because
I'll freak out my neighbors but as you
can see I'm at the crash in Ocean Beach
and there's no one to close so someone
told me I gotta go
if you also have amazing gameplay
segments you captured from our games
spread the joy and submit them on the
link displayed on your screen right now
all right guys it is time for us to wrap
up this pre-show don't forget to stay
tuned from our post show featuring a
deep dive into the world of Assassin's
Creed Valhalla thanks a lot for watching
this pre-show and enjoy the soft board
to fire
meet the devs
join us
hi everyone I'm Neil and Kumar and I'm
very excited to be co-hosting the first
Ubisoft forward with the talented use of
Magee today's show is all about getting
up close and in depth with all the
exciting games we have in production
here at Ubisoft I'm users but there's no
time to waste so let's head straight
from the streets of futuristic London
and see what the hackers of dead Secor
getting into the illegal painting is
spreading subversive and possible
messaging over the last few weeks of the
slum Dhin are not the work of several
people as was originally believed
authorities recommend not to approach
the individual first they came for the
florist and I did not speak out because
I was not a foreigner
then they came for the protesters and I
did not speak out
because I was not a protest
then they came for the journalists and I
did not speak out because I was not a
journalist
and then they come for street artists I
did not speak
because I am NOT a straight artist
now realized that eventually that come
for me and there would be no one left to
speak for me
sorry
after a long night London is
oh well well welcome to the resistance
there's a welcome gift tell me it was a
bloody costume party try it off the new
key suspect has been identified as David
Ford a 43 year old London taxi driver he
has no but is currently believed to be a
terrorist I'm Clint Hocking Clint has
been a longtime creative force here at
Ubisoft and now he's bringing this
vision to watchdogs region so yeah what
we just saw was an amazing short film by
the director Alberto Miele ago that was
inspired by watchdogs Legion and looks
at at the game and the universe and the
characters through his incredible
artistic vision and visual style city
needs a resistance like the film
watchdogs Legion tells the story of
ordinary heroes setting aside their
differences in order to come together as
a collective and to fight for a positive
change
you can literally recruit and play
anyone who you see in the open world
you profile people that are interesting
to you you help them with their problem
you play their origin mission
just help me get some closure and I'll
do whatever you want sounds like a
dedsec problem leave it to us and that's
how you recruit them into your team and
then they become the heroes of the game
and and the stars of your story and what
are you doing in my flat
you Fabian please think more underground
I'm tickled but think more underground
get sick yeah right now I'm Che Guevara
you're done and they make the story not
only you know unique to them but unique
to you as the player and personal to you
because they're you know heroes that
you've chosen and invested in what would
I say to fans I guess I'd say you know
take care of yourselves stay safe
welcome to the resistance
our London town
a modern metropolis built on history and
prosperity only took 12,000 years to
build it up and one night to tear it all
down
oh my god
listen ami you know your units to move
in and lock down the city
with London under attack by a mysterious
terrorist the government turns to a
private military company called Albion
to keep everyone safe what could
possibly go wrong ladies and gentlemen
mr. Nigel Cass CEO of Albion he's kindly
stepped out to establish order
understand this I will not allow anyone
not even myself to jeopardize this he
will stop at nothing to permanently
control the city
London will be the first city in the
world to be made truly safe
Nigel's not the only opportunist who's
taken a liking to this fair city meet
Mary Kelly head of the most powerful
crime syndicate in London they soon
spread the word
she and her goons are using the dark web
to sell everything from party pills to
people I've got to keep tracks on my
merchandise bhai you make me a slave you
do not want to ruffle her feathers with
the city out on its ass it now falls on
you to build a resistance and take back
London any of the brave London as you
see walking the streets can be recruited
into your team like him
or even
everyone could become your next secret
weapon your first mission we need to get
some dirt on Nigel Cass and that means
breaking into Albion headquarters inside
the Tower of London all the hardy souls
you see here are people we have
recruited from the streets of London
they all have unique abilities and
you're free to tackle this mission with
whoever you like my eyes
like everyone in dedsec either can hack
pretty much whatever but as a
construction worker he has a particular
set of tools that make him handy
he could even call his own cargo drone
perfect for gate-crashing when you're
not invited and who needs a regular old
gun when you have a bloody male gut
Omega sorry to eat [ __ ]
perhaps we could approach this mission
differently if you'd rather keep your
distance we've got you covered
amy is a drone expert what have we here
a real tech connoisseur
hate spiders but love this one what an
adorable creepy-crawler class the place
up a drone expert does have the unique
ability to summon their own drones this
little darling is fast and stealthy
I'm reading incoming drones
she could also hack enemy drones turning
the tide in her favor
and if you are not into direct
confrontation there are more ways than
one to get the job done
recruiting an Albion officer like
Brielle here might be challenging but
it'll get you inside restricted Albion
areas don't mind me just doing recon for
a bunch of insurgents however do
anything suspicious and she'll probably
wind up with a bullet in the back of her
head
we're missing the human element here I
can get the defense minister on the line
right now if you feel you must criminals
running our streets illegals threatening
our families the police commissioner
himself assassinated by terrorists well
that seems to be enough evidence next up
we're crashing Mary Kelly's organ
farming operation and putting a stop to
it and we need a hard not for this
impairing our frontal lobe again are we
bugs don't disturb me in my natural
habitat say hello to Mickey the man
lives for his team that put another
arrow on the chest and doesn't mind
getting his hands dirty
he does have a slight drinking problem
though
and these boss down ah well we'll come
back to him you know what let's go with
someone a bit more professional
it's almost crass to call him a hit man
some might even call him an artist
here's the fasted responsible done and
dusted bad not bad if I do say so any
not everyone in London is a legendary
assassin or a super spy but everyone can
be a hero
so get out there find the best recruits
and build your resistance
it's time to take back London
plunging the player into a living
breathing city teeming with unique
locales and characters has always been a
central pillar of the watchdog series so
what goes into building those worlds
here's Amanda Munn to tell us more my
name is Amanda Mundt
I'm a Louisville artist on watchdogs
Legion at Ubisoft Toronto being a level
artist I think is the coolest job in
video games because we do get the
freedom to to kind of like pick and
choose what little details we want to
depict and we get ample opportunities to
tell the stories that we want to tell in
the spaces that were assigned to I have
the capacity to hide things and you know
like small little Easter eggs in AC
unity there was a boat somewhere in the
world that was covered in cats and then
it happened again and watchdogs too and
there may or may not be something in
London that is a boat filled with cats
in some capacity I was fortunate enough
to go to e3 last year some of the people
that I was showing our demo to were from
London so no matter where I dropped them
in the city they would go oh my god this
feels like Camden is you know this feels
like suffered this feels like
Westminster when people are talking
about some detail that I've put into the
world and they're excited about it like
I feel so good as somebody who you know
builds these worlds with care I love it
and now some news for brawlhalla fans in
just a few weeks you'll be able to
battle it out with your favorite legends
on iOS and Android devices
three-two-one
you
and now whether you need a Tom Clancy
action fix on the go I want to dive back
into one of the most beloved Fantasy
franchises in gaming we've got you
covered
Hut jack mo chain is down
request air support target northeast
rooftop bat danger close be deployed now
get back in your south
hey fix it don't make me regret this
speaking of Tom Clancy it's been five
years since Rainbow six siege first
launched and the community has never
been stronger in celebration of this
milestone Ubisoft Montreal has put
together a special video to thank all
the amazing players and developers that
have helped siege become the game it is
today
in December 2015 a small team released
Rainbow six siege
a game built on a strong vision
creativity competitiveness and team play
Wordsworth the Femina some settle deeply
metal music - sweet song [ __ ] Rohullah
sweetest Ali to purchase tell you see in
his phone that original vision was
quickly adopted by our passionate
community propelling it to a whole new
level
this is such a special moment and being
at one year anniversary of Rainbow six
now game being a stronger than ever I'm
hopeful I used to didn't we hand in the
past it means the world to us
but we also had our share of challenges
health that touches upon subject like
much making connectivity all those
aspects are absolutely critical to the
experience of the player
through it all we're always driven by
you our community and together we grow
stronger
there is no sequel plan and we are here
for the next 10 years to expect more
than guzik's in your life for quite some
time
truely's should say salam ala resultado
Butantan should have seizure the
authority would do not develop now 60
million players strong for just getting
started
from the devs that build the game to the
community that plays it thank you
if you haven't tried it yet dive into
our new operation steel wave update
available now and take a similar Z out
first spin
a few days ago we introduced you all to
a brand new multiplayer shooter now it's
time to venture into the hyper escape
wait what was that a hack in the hyper
scape that's not supposed to be there
well let me get you all up to speed okay
about 30 years ago
everything that we feared about our
future started to come true we made some
good decisions we made some bad
decisions actually we made a lot of bad
decisions so here we are ten billion
souls living in the crush of the mega
cities but the people at Prisma changed
everything
they gave everyone a way out the hyper
scape
in the hyper scape the biggest draw by
far is crown rush this is where anyone
can become somewhere
if you get good a crown rush it can
change your life but strange things have
been happening lately
rumors of people getting hurt
users disappearing from the real world a
darker secret lies at the heart of hyper
scape and we have to find it
some of us are searching for a way up
some of us for a way out and for others
a new way all together that's what
brings us to the edge of the future to
the hyper scape
I'm Jesse creative director on
hyperscale
JC's work on Far Cry primal and multiple
Prince of Persia titles has established
him as a top creative here at Ubisoft
for me what's exciting is we started
building it from scratch see me grow
adding ideas is really cool
hello contender welcome to the high
priest King the game takes place in 2054
it's in a future where humanity has
grown a little doctoral one of the
companies there they are launching
what's called the hyper escape which is
a virtual world and the Internet of the
future it's the place where everything
converges within the digital world
there is a battle royale that takes
place in the atrocity of neo Arcadia
then you also introduce a lot of new
things you get the opportunity to be
back you on the rooftops grew into
interiors where it's much more narrow
much more stressful
you get to go to the landmarks where
there's more opportunities to get full
items but also more players so it's a
risk/reward kind of deal
we introduced the notion of hacks
special abilities that you can pick up
on the fly to adapt your tactics with
hacks you can do things like tell about
yourself you can wrap yourself into a
ball and bounce around the battlefield
so a lot of abilities that let you have
fun at the tap toys that you can play
with finally it's made as a spectacle so
all the viewers will be able to interact
with the game on different levels
through the twitch extension so every
few minutes there's going to be a vote
and viewers will be able to decide what
effect they want to affect the whole
batter so things like changing the
gravity infinite ammo or stuff like that
so players while this happens really
have to adapt to all kinds of stuff that
is happening for me it's really exciting
because right now as we speak we are
launching the open beta and so it's
going to be available for free to play
for all PC players worldwide and I
really want to thank all the players all
the streamers and all of the world
participated in tech test and we
participate in the open beta here's the
short limbs of what you can expect
learn how it's done
till time
let's show them what I made it
Gotha
watch closely here we go
cannot you see
the digital world of the hyper scape
gave our artists and developers
incredible freedom when it came to
designing characters production manager
annamaria mooskaa is going to take us
behind the scenes of character design my
name is anna maria mooskaa I'm the
production manager for characters and
weapons on hyper scape we have paid an
exceptional amount of detail to our
characters we switch different outfits
different fashion statements different
tattoos different materials until we see
them as real individuals as real people
so the second you pick a character you
see them in-game you understand what
their motivations are and what drives
them and what challenges them this was
the first lineup of characters is our
default base but even starting from the
hair down everything has been
meticulously thought of with this person
actually like this type of outfit with
this person enjoy the type of tattoos
that were putting on them will they
actually like to be in this body each
season we plan to produce new outfits
for these characters so we're hoping
some of our players are gonna see the
effort and maybe even correlate some of
the accessories to what's gonna happen
in the game
I'm very excited to see it in people's
hands as we move into the next
generation of gaming Ubisoft has been
working closely with console makers to
take advantage of all the extraordinary
capabilities these new consoles will
offer now we have a special guest to
tell us a little more everyone Phil
Spencer from Xbox with watchdogs lesion
Ubisoft is supporting smart delivery so
you will get the absolute best version
of the game on any version of Xbox
you're playing on on series X you'll get
to take advantage of the amazing work
the team is done with DirectX ray
tracing to create an absolutely
immersive version of London like you've
never seen before
Ubisoft as a unique ability to create
immersive worlds setting a new bar that
continues to drive our industry forward
I'm a huge fan of Assassin's Creed I
love the time I've spent exploring the
world in Assassin's Creed Odyssey and I
can't wait for you to see the gameplay
from Assassin's Creed bahala that's
coming up now all right we know you've
been waiting to hear more about this
game since it was announced back in
April and now it's time for a deep dive
into the world of Vikings my name is
Judy FAI and I'm the producer of
Assassin's Creed Valhalla so a couple of
weeks ago we announced Assassin's Creed
Valhalla and the reaction from the fans
was just amazing the time period of
Vikings is really really inspiring when
we did our research we found that you
know they were not mindless barbarians
Vikings were actually farmers trying to
find new lands for them to settle and so
they had really human motivations so for
us to have this opportunity to tell have
the real story about Vikings and kind of
separate ourselves from the myths and
the folklore is really something that
drove us to make this game the team went
to Norway in England take the same roads
that the Vikings did to really
experience what it meant to be a Viking
at that time and then leaving Norway
which is barren but majestic and just
coming by boat in England and see those
rolling green hills full of sheep full
of life is just this moment that most
likely the Vikings felt as well you need
to see this land of opportunity
and this is exactly the feeling we want
players to experience in this game
it is a personal adventure you know it
is the story of a for a Viking chieftain
a4 is either a male or a female you
decide when you start the game they will
have to leave Norway to settle in
England because you just can't live in
Norway anymore there's too much
political pressure no resources
available obviously in England
it's full of anglo-saxons and other
people and they don't really want you
there so you will have to fight your way
there to kind of build your own
settlement and see your clan prosper
Vikings were brutal warriors
and the fact that they were mastering a
lot of weapons coming from the medieval
times really inspired us to kind of
revamp the fight system to leverage the
brutality and the intensity of Viking
combat Vikings were not only fighting
face-to-face they were masters of
stealth and deception when needed they
used basically any sort of tactics they
could use to win the battle so we want
to portray the full range of combat that
you can imagine coming from the Vikings
we are very happy to finally be able to
show you the game we're all been working
on so please enjoy this deep dive into
Sasson screen Valhalla
in Assassin's Creed Valhalla you will
relive the epic saga of the Viking
invasion of England
you play as a boy a Viking from Norway
who will lead his or her battle-hardened
warriors across the North Sea to the
British Isles a var is driven by an
ambitious goal to build a thriving Norse
settlement in a hostile land it is time
we go a Viking
today we raid tomorrow we may built
England is a Dark Age tangle of broken
kingdoms and warring dynasties a land of
opportunity and riches as you prowling
lays rivers by longship you may Rhea
locations you spot from the shoreline
ground your ship and blow your horn to
lead your raiding crew into battle
your crew will assist you in all your
raids fighting enemies battering down
doors and stealing cargo too heavy for
one set of arms whatever riches and
resources you pillage may be used to
develop your settlement giving you
access to useful services better tools
and new settlers at the heart of your
settlement is the Alliance map it will
serve as a record of the allies you have
made and a guide for future
opportunities the Viking Age was a time
of warriors and legends in Valhalla you
will find the largest variety of enemies
ever assembled in an assassin's Creed
game in three archetype offers a unique
challenge some will coordinate with our
allies for special attacks while others
will use nearby objects to their
advantage
including the bodies of fallen warriors
to face these attacks you must find and
exploit your opponent's weaknesses to
gain the upper hand take the fight to
your foes with a host of brutal new
combat abilities snare them with a vital
harpoon pummel them at throwing axes
incapacitate them with the new stun
system to keep them at a distance or
finish the model
jool will any two weapons you wish to
unleash a deadly combination of attacks
customize your fighting style as you see
fit and become a legendary Viking
warrior
all combinations of weapons are
available to dual-wield including to
shields
not all situations call for violence in
this new land a Viking must find a way
to adapt as a Ivar is not welcome in
England you may need to outsmart your
enemies avoiding unwanted attention in
towns and bustling cities use a VARs
hoody and cloak to blend with crowds and
slip past watchful eyes an unseen hunter
among the people
from capital cities and villages to the
dense forests and rolling hills of
England exploration is vital to keeping
yourself sharp you must feed off the
land if you hope to endure hunt and
forage to replenish your health and
fortify your equipment search pagan
temples and Roman ruins for new
activities and challenges to strengthen
yourself and your settlement
the more you explore the more of
England's secrets you will reveal but as
you push deeper into England the enemy
will push back in a series of climactic
moments Assassin's Creed Valhalla will
feature massive assaults in which you
who lead a Wars army into battle against
heavily guarded Saxon fortresses
we fight for your land and tomorrow we
rebuild for Easter reach the riester
Assassin's Creed Valhalla will transport
you to wondrous and haunted lands
inspired by Norse myths and England's
pagan roots it will challenge and
surprise Thank You Beth with
unforgettable characters thrilling
triumphs and tragic losses giving you
the chance with your own Viking saga
ninth century England is truly unlike
anything the franchise has seen before
Assassin's Creed Valhalla
were released this holiday season on
Xbox series X PlayStation 5 Xbox one ps4
PC and stadia we're close to wrapping up
today but before we go our CEO Yves hemo
is here to share a few words I hope you
will have enjoyed what you have seen
today and that you will love playing
these games I am proud of our teams for
delivering and ambitious broad and
creative lineup of games and we haven't
shown you everything yet in fact we have
a lot more to come so you will have
another Ubisoft forward to reveal even
more about our upcoming games but before
ending this show we have one more thing
to share with you
it's beautiful middle perfect but
useless I have something for you Diego
give me your hands
papa
No the grenade is simple it has four
basic parts the shell which contains the
explosive defuse the handle and of
course the pin
what do you think breathe the pin simply
off the handle in place it is only when
you let go that this grenade goes boom
follow me now
I am el president which means that
someday you will be President
and our people they do not know how to
be happy they are torn apart by opinions
noise indecision strangled by their own
freedoms and even if you have love in
your heart even if you want what's best
for them if you only want to save them
from themselves
they will hate you do everything you say
do believe we'll be wrong
they will answer you screams
for you either
and monster
and give you
this
so you tell me are you
are you a post
our country is like this granny except
it has two basic parts
and you and you must crush them knives
and died a war we all
you understand now
and with that we're wrapping up our
first ubisoft forward today we've seen
the next generation of assassin's creed
the birth of a resistance in watchdogs
legions the cyber chaos of hyper scape
in the epic reveal of our crazed newest
installment along with so much more
remember we'll be back later this year
with another ubisoft forward filled with
tons of game news and updates thanks for
joining us
hey everyone welcome to the Ubisoft
forward post show my name is Yousef
Nikita and this is assassin screen
Valhalla we're gonna take a deep dive
into about 30 minutes of gameplay and
we're joined by a very special guest
here hey everyone this is Phillip Baum
otherwise known as fizz
I am the quest director on Assassin's
Creed Valhalla
so fizz we're setting up here for what
looks like an epic encounter tell us
exactly what's going on here yeah so
here we're midway through the the quest
that were showing for you before here
we're looking at the assault of burke
castle so these are big moments that
usually sort of culminate at the end of
the story and so here a bar or viking
Raider is taking a group of Raiders and
birds into burg castle to go and take
down ruied and his clan so who exactly
is ruied and why does a horse or want to
pick a fight with them basically ruh it
comes into play about halfway through
this story aren't we're at the beginning
of the arca this is something that that
happens before bread basically caused a
lot of turmoil within the territory and
Oswalt who's the sort of elderman to be
to inherit this territory needs your
help to take him down as well having
just been defeated in a previous
question so here this is revenge but
also accomplishing your ultimate goal
so as you're talking we're seeing some
of the combat of Valhalla can you tell
us a little bit about the changes to
combat the summer we wanted to basically
add a lot of new mechanics to it so we
added like some dual wielding for the
player like a stun system in there and
we really needed to do this to sort of
portray that sort of the brutality that
comes with being a Viking the same aho
sort of fits in
it's the time and the character
possible
he lives shut your eyes Twix pie here a
war has taken her entire army through
the assault and finally it's revealed
that our our elderman our ally Oswald is
still alive and ruied has some captive
to Jane's fighting over a filthy saxon
or son this suede is your price come and
get him
so now that we've seen that all these
alive we have ruined within our sights
what's the next step here so the next
move for a var is to finally face off
against Britain she has her allies they
can take care of the rest of the army
now it's time to go one-on-one against
through it in one of our boss battles
and it's worth pointing out actually
that here what we're showing is the
player going and facing off against
Rouen aggressively but you we tend to
always have a to support a 360 degree
approach in these things so if Clara
could have approached us a little bit
more stealthy and gotten at least like a
good critical hit on either ruied or is
wolf and so you can play this a little
bit more strategically if that's your
place tonight so we're not only fighting
ruied here but also his pet wolf right
you're one of my preferred strategies is
to eliminate the wolf first just focus
fire on him it takes at least one
opponent out of the combat now ruied
will have extra abilities that come into
play if you do eliminate his wolf but I
think having one opponent less in the
battlefield makes for a good strategy in
the whole
all your efforts only the cold Tiger
meat behind the way
why don't they should be wolf kissed
they froze it's not treated as equals we
are better than this and all of them do
not drag me down to the sewage
swallowing you throw in with these
wastrels
these are give swine evil no he should
be tried before God a lawful assembly
all right so we've defeated ruin and we
freed Oswald what comes next
Oswald in this case prefers for rue it
to be kept alive and so you basically
have to choose are you gonna go against
his wishes or to stay true to your
nature so we have this choice to make
but before we get into that I want to
rewind a little bit because we just did
this big grand assault but Averell
couldn't have done it alone she clearly
had to recruit some folks along the way
get some troops get some allies so let's
actually rewind and see how we went
about first gathering those troops right
so when coming up to an assault it's a
game of numbers ie vork can go into
pretty much any location and be a
stealthy Viking eliminating some of the
assets which ultimately would be a
strategy you can do that and you'll have
some some of the ingredients or of the
assets there that will have been
sabotage but you still need a army so
here what we're seeing is a war going
around the countryside and raising what
we call aford which is the men and the
women of the territory come up and fight
in the name of a king so here a war is
going around and try and convince people
to fight in the name of Oswald to
finally take down the oppressor that is
ruied defending you will you not do the
same what don't even defend some lost
cause
yes oh she's really using like the the
image and like the the leadership that
ELLs will have what he meant to the
people in his name she's going to
recruit these people pretty words day
but a minute they voted to have their
own battles to fight so we're told by
this Reeves that there are troops there
allies that he could add to our cause
but first we sorted me to do him a favor
is that right yeah so obviously these
people have been run down by ruied and
the impact he's had on the territory so
I think a lot of these people have sort
of lost hope and so you need to show
them that there is hope and so here a
var is basically helping them take back
one of their their prized locations by
taking a couple men and raiding a nearby
Township basically taking it back to the
people and showing that there's there's
a reason to continue fighting and then
get them on your side
when a four does this obviously you have
access to a full suite of abilities so
again the improvements that we've done
to the flight system you have some
brutal axe throwing in there you have
archery or like a range combat abilities
in there as well so really again like
depending on what your play style is you
can customize your loadout and go in
there
how you wish
Faye's we just saw this giant pulse go
out what exactly was that so that is
actually this is what we called the Odin
site the inside is basically our
interpretation of the Eagle vision from
previous games so we thought it was good
to sort of bring that back
it's basically a horse intuition it's
how she perceives the world when Blair
uses that you can it'll highlight
basically interactive objects like
things that will bring her an advantage
so we'll have arrows like health
consumables that are in there so it
really is like a good way of sort of
understanding the world and showing you
like things that you can go and touch
yeah I mean speaking of things we can
touch we just picked up this awesome new
weapon it's something we wanted to play
with on Assassin's create Phil Halle
where we have fewer weapons in the game
but you can invest in the more so if
they become your weapon and so depending
what your preferred playstyle is or your
preferred weapon type then you can go
and choose I'm gonna I'm gonna fight
with this weapon and invest heavily into
that not only are we
looting weapons but we see something
here called The Book of Knowledge he
tell us a little bit more about that
they unlock skills for the players oh
here you can see the Valkyrie dive that
has just been unlocked we have these
spread out throughout the world so again
to promote exploration and discovery as
you travel through the world and you
explore locations you can find these
books that will add abilities that you
can go and invest in put into your
loadout then go into the different
locations with the different quests in
the game and use though depending on
what your playstyle is now we've
recaptured this village we've secured
more troops for our assault let's jump
back now and figure out what we want to
do with Rouen
the rightful king of East Anglia has
spared your life today and so it will be
compassion is a virtue suited for anyone
able including you thank you
before decided to let him live Rueda is
really angry about that being a North
Viking being put to the death in battle
is your road to Valhalla so he was
basically denied access to Valhalla in
this situation obviously all of these
decisions come into play later on in the
game so we have very difficult decisions
for the player to make we didn't want to
have easy decisions yeah you know when I
was playing I decided to listen to
Oswald and spare ruins life but what
exactly is the relationship like between
a bore and all so the relationship
between a [ __ ] and Oswald is is it's an
alliance it's basically a void
surrounded by territories that initially
getting into England are hostile towards
her and obviously if you want to set up
a new settlement you want to have make
sure that your neighbor is friendly so
if you're nice Anglia Oswald as the man
for the job
we're putting him into a position of
power would help her source secure her
territory so earlier on to the territory
a vork comes in here meets Oswald the
problems he had with dread are sort of
put to light and going through the arc
you basically help him deal with red and
and aligning basically Danes with Saxons
in one territory so we've completed the
assault we've got our hands dirty with
some combat taken down ruied we have
this big open region of East Anglia so
before we head off to Oswald wedding
what do you say we head out have some
fun and see what we can get into in the
open world
that sounds great so we see a cat here
with a speech bubble above it and you
best believe if you let me talk to a cat
I'm gonna talk to a cat yeah these are
some of our
most some of my favorite moments
actually in the game where we put in put
out a whole bunch of events throughout
the territory and it's sort of rewards
again exploration going around it's a
it's a chance for us also to sort of
showcase a different side of a lure a
lot of the quests were to deal worth
more with like politics and warfare and
this shows a slightly more human nature
to her so it permitted us to explore
that character a little bit more and so
here basically like a year you're trying
to help a kid with his cat and
ultimately get that cat to sort of join
your crew as a cat Raider you just said
cat Raider way too casually you told me
I could have a cat Viking Raider on my
long show that's that's exactly what I'm
telling you yes so yes as you're riding
around the the rivers of England you
would see a cat basically walking around
your long ship keeping your Viking
raiders company of the Viking longship
we're seeing some of the gameplay here
now you talked a little bit about how
that works and functions in Valhalla
yeah so starting out on this project I
think the Viking longship is one of the
the biggest images that we all have when
we think about Vikings in our game and
so Vikings had this this awesome design
for long ship that had a very shallow
Hall so permitted them to go very far
inland very quickly and you could
basically disembark the Viking raiders
like on pretty much any shore we added
that into the game where you can
basically sail up to any location and
then just decide to disembark with your
guys and raid a location moodle's
treasure get back in the ship and then
continue really a sailing down the river
to your next opportunity so I know past
Assassin's Creed games allowed for songs
and things like that to be sung on ships
will Valhalla have a similar version of
that yeah so this is something we
actually wanted the cruiser ship to
become like you're at your home away
from home so we added stories and songs
into
the ship so basically as a player is
going around you could decide to have
your skull soar sing a song for you as
you row down the river but you can also
decide depending on who the Raiders are
in your ship to hear more about their
life so you can actually queue up
stories and they'll give you a little
bit more background in who they are so
you get to know your your sort of
fighters as you're travelling around the
world which is a cool moment so here
we're seeing a bit of a different view
what exactly are we looking at we had
this on previous Assassin's where you
would like ride on your horse and you
could pull out have the rode the horse
sort of follow the track we have a
similar thing for the ship where you can
put up your sails
it's cruise control for the ship so you
can pull back taking the scenery listen
to some songs or some stories and just
take it all in
so you know speaking of Viking songs we
have an activity here that's not exactly
singing but kind of related right yeah
so here all we have is what we call
flighting which was an activity that
Norse people will partake in they would
like to have a battle of wits and and
sort of poetry where insults would be
thrown back and forth between each other
the idea was to try and have a good
insult but also to have a good rhythm
and a good rhyme in there so it's
basically a precursor to rap battles
here's the silver now begin
to all those whom I speak they say Ava
was a clod
then you're speaking to fools and their
knowledge is flawed well how exactly do
you go about being successful in one of
these trick behind a good flight
was to choose the right insult I didn't
find the right cadence and then trying
to find what rhymed the best known for
my might
interesting interesting silent whispers
all claim that you're terribly dense
then you've clearly miss hurt them my
wit is immense oh you looked out with
that one
well what a surprise I evolve the Raven
clan is a true talent I'm shocked don't
believe everything you hear unless it
touches on my flight team then heed
every word take the coin so now that
we've proven our sharp tongue and wit I
think it's time for a bit more relaxing
activity so we're fishing here yeah
that's it so we gave a boar a fishing
line so you can actually throw out a lot
and and go catch some fish this is used
basically to to play into our new health
loop where the player will lose health
and in the world and it doesn't
automatically generate it regenerate
like we would have in the past so you
actually have to go out and get some
some supplies so you'll find mushrooms
and some food that you can gather but
here's like we you can also catch them
fish and consume that to regain some
health if we also some will sometimes
have it in in certain quests so it's a
good way to sort of chill out on the
side of the the water and just again
take it all in
so this is what we call one of our
offering altars so the idea is that you
you find these around the world and you
make offerings to it and so it will take
like animal parts and stuff that you can
find crap the world here what you're
seeing though is sort of like a fancy
version of it where as you do your
offering you get interrupted by some
some kids that basically come and steal
your stuff so there's just a way for us
to sort of showcase that like the
systems and activities in the world can
sort of play in with some some quests
and some little bit so it's our worry to
sort of dress up these moments and make
it all fit inside the whole experience
yeah this seems like a really sort of
unexpected turn for what I thought was
gonna be as kind of a simple interaction
yeah and it's really what we're trying
to do with these events is to is to give
another dimension a war rather than just
you know the pure rawr Viking or the
politician because you can imagine at
some point that will hold girl if you're
always telling that that that version
the character so it lets us really go
into the death of who is a var what
motivates her how she can interact with
the world outside of warfare and
politics and it also showcases like a
different facet of the world at the same
time it's not only so it just widens the
breadth of the stories that we can tell
so who exactly are these two children
these are kids of you staying the they
are going through tough times with
whatever route it's been doing to the
territory and so they're just here
trying to survive and and basically
exploit the people that are there to
make offerings it was kind of nice to
see that a wasn't really necessarily
upset at them for stealing and you know
after you talk to them you have a choice
of helping
you can give them food money or you know
maybe just say hey good luck on your way
and this is something we also wanted to
do a lot likely so here we're doing an
event we do any quests as well but we
want to do you know give a lot of this
agency into players hands so that they
can sort of shape a voor a little bit
who she is or represents them a little
bit more and they can roleplay that a
little bit better and again it just
gives her like a little bit more
humanity in these in these moments
provide for small walkers
here large Walker a necklace yes it's a
st. Martin sealed you're welcome here
anytime large Walker you're one of us
now visit us ok I will take care now
small green walkers so I think a see
veterans might recognize this here but
what exactly is a war chasing down yeah
so here you're seeing it for running
down one of our tattoo images so this is
challenging the player on free run
abilities but also for fans of the
series sort of pulling at their
heartstrings for some beloved features
so are we gonna be able to tattoo a
board yes by collecting these tattoos
you actually bring them to back to your
settlement and then you can customize
different body parts having different
tattoos everywhere so again another form
of expression and it's sort of to
represent that Bolton that Viking
culture one of my favorite things when I
was just out there exploring East Anglia
was coming upon a house or building and
realizing that there was a chest inside
but that there was no easy way in and in
this case I saw all the doors were
barred but I knew that because there was
a chest in there there must have been
some way to get inside so I went around
the back and you know found a way in
yeah I'm glad you actually caught onto
that you're pointing at something that
we wanted to work on a lot on Valhalla
where we wanted the exploration to make
you feel smarter so we played a lot with
puzzle solving so making sure that every
house that you find sort of appeals you
like a draws your attention and then
when you want to come and explore it's
not it's not given to you you still have
to work for a little bit so it'll
challenge you on your observation skills
logic just trying to find how do I get
into this so we play a lot with level
design quest design to offer challenges
to players and you basically come out of
it like with a better
for the exploration but you also get to
see more of a story behind the in
visited locations which we've crafted so
it gave us a little bit more time to
sort of slow down the experience and and
tell a different version of a story a
poor victim of someone's jarring yeah I
mean speaking about exploration and just
finding things out in the world I was
just wandering and came across this
clearing and found this kind of morbid
altar yeah so this is this is one of our
bigger events that we we have scattered
in the world
so as a more explorers she can find
altars like this and by interacting with
them here it's a trap that's been set
for by by this character named Regan now
there's a bigger story behind all this
there's multiple steps to it later on so
this is one of the moments it permits us
to go into a slightly more mystical
realm and play with a boss fight that
has more magical abilities if we will
and basically have this awesome boss
fight in the middle of the swamps and so
here the abilities that you see Regan
using like are a little bit on the
mystical side of things what's happening
is a war at the beginning in that trap
is poison and so she starts sort of
loosening seeing the world and a sort of
different light and filter and so that
that's sort of what lets us go into this
this the the realm of the weird
so we just saw here that Regan belongs
to something called the daughters of
Leary oh yeah that's correct by finding
the other daughters you'll get a little
bit more backstory on who they are so we
don't want to spoil that too much but it
creates like a sort of greatest story
that is not on the main path in any way
but it's still very rich and adds to the
lore of this world and actually plays
into history so we just had a really
exciting really intense boss battle I
think it's time for something a little
bit more relaxing and calming now yeah
it's all here it's all about pacing
yourself with the highs and the lows so
here we have a low chill moment of what
we call building a cairn
so a VAR as she explores the world we'll
find these sort of meditative areas
where you have a pile of rocks that you
could just stack on one on top of
another using physics and I mean yeah
the ultimate goal is to try and get the
highest pile of rocks but really it's
about taking in the sights
relaxing taking a step back and and bill
just building something together we
stacked stones into karent's these yes
think of this as a test of mind and wait
a sec the cairn stones high and wide
into any shape you like I mean you can
spend as much time as you want building
these things making them size you want
as weird as you want I'm sure like a lot
of these stuff will end up on the
internet like people comparing
structures and the cool thing is that
once you've built it and you decide to
get out of it it sort of stays there and
so that's yours right and until the
moment where you come back and you want
to build a new one is it's sort of cool
that we were able to to give that to
players to express themselves at this
point in the demo we've explored easy
anglia
we've met some children we've broken
into a house we fought a boss and built
a Karen I think now it's finally time to
go and head off to Oswald's wedding
yeah so this is the this is the moment
it's all been building up to oh by the
moment you get into the Therese Tori
sort of like mentioned
of all that he's trying to get married
with his deign lady and so as you go
through the arc that's sort of like the
underlying thread really it's about
ruied creating turmoil in the territory
and helping all sort of get above that
and and show that he's a good leader and
so you finally after going through all
of that arc finally get these two
together go through there they're wet at
their wedding and you're invited to
attend the ceremony and then all the
activities and fun times that come
afterwards
yeah as much as we've seen the brutal
side of England we nice to see the
joyous side of it as well yeah and it's
something we really wanted to play on in
in Valhalla where being a Viking is not
only about being a Raider or warrior I
mean there's revelry there's feasting
there's partying that goes and like if
if someone knows how to party it's a
Viking and so here this is one of our
opportunities to sort of show that show
what a sort of Viking gathering is and
what's cool here is it's a it's a good
alliance of Norse culture with Saxon
culture sort of smashing those two
things together and building bridges
yeah I mean what's a wedding without
some drunk archery right yeah so
anything can happen in a Viking event
right before yeah here here they just
get drunks and shoot some arrows
challenge steady old and ready yourself
for the wedding race the king and his
bride against all my king
so here we see the decision I made this
bear really came back to bite us yeah
that that's the decision you made coming
back so as we said before all your
decisions have consequences and this is
a big one I accept your basically
presented with the option to sort of
step in for Oswald fight the fight for
him or let him go and fight his own
fight yeah you know personally I chose
the fight myself because I thought a war
is the type of finish and a dead King
cannot keep his oath let me finish this
Oh
Cutlass on your swine I'll play the wolf
kissed then hang you with your own time
how does this encounter would ruin our
previous life so at this point you've
eliminated his wolf so it's just him and
so he he's angry at this point and so he
will start using his his big gun
abilities like fairly earlier on in the
fight so it's way more vicious way
faster there's less strategy he goes
literally swords blazing at you um and
so this is a fight to the death
and of course here like this is a
decision you made to go and fight him
but there's multiple outcomes to this
scenario you could have left all's wall
fight his own fight and prove basically
his station as the rightful leader if
you had eliminated through it obviously
this would not have happened it would
have been a slightly more joyous
occasion but ultimately in all scenarios
you still have an alliance with Oswald
he's proven to be the right leader for
this territory and to be a good Ally for
you I promised you an alliance now you
have it and one day I will need you to
make good on that alliance so we're
about to take off from the wedding but a
board decides it's a good idea to check
up on her friend thinner yeah so fin
affinor is probably one of the more
recurring characters in this arc you get
to meet him very wrong
he's very endearing character sort of
used to have a Viking life sort of
misses it and going through all these
adventures together
sort of like lights that fire back and
so he's willing to join you in your
raiders so he's one of many Raiders that
you'll you'll encounter in the game and
you can sort of recruit bring back home
and then have them sort of join you on
your adventures on the longship you can
tell you these stories that were telling
you about you get a little bit to know a
little bit more about him so again it's
a fun way to sort of discover more about
these characters that you meet and bring
him along for adventures together
together I've gathered my things well
folks we've come to the end of our
Assassin's Creed and Valhalla
playthrough Fizz thank you so much for
joining us when and where can people
play it Assassin's Creed Mahalo we'll be
out on Xbox series X and PlayStation 5
and is coming to Xbox one Playstation 4
PC and stadia on November 17th
you
hello everyone a happy Sunday and
welcome to the GameSpot post show for
ubisoft forward July edition because
apparently we're getting another one
it's some undetermined time I'm Lucy you
joined today by Michael hi I'm what up
and more Hussein hello everyone now
obviously we are going to be discussing
all the games that Ubisoft showed off in
today's you beasts afford event but it
would be completely remiss of us to not
talk about the broader context and what
is happening at Ubisoft
as a company right now we have a
platform we're gonna use it they started
off this morning I will read the tweet
out Ubisoft for word comes during a time
of big internal change because all the
content has been pre-recorded we wanted
to recognize that the issues we're
currently dealing with won't be
addressed directly in the show we still
have significant work to do and are
committed to this process we will
provide more updates soon I'm not going
to go too deep into the details but
obviously there have been allegations of
sexual abuse harassment and other abuses
people have stepped down they were well
golden parachuting out of the company
resigning from their positions
personally speaking it is not that hard
to record a clip and put it into a show
I find this excuse quite frankly very
disrespectful for all the people the
thousands of people who still work at
Ubisoft is all very well and good this
is obviously a promotional show they are
promoting the games but they need to
have that commitment that they are
working towards actually improving and
what better way than to use this
showcase to fully commit to that future
for thousands of employees and this the
survivors and the victims I'm very
disappointed personally speaking yeah
yes I want to yes it's pretty
unacceptable that a company that large
that is able to you know create games on
a global field using utilizing multiple
teams
development marketing PR is unable to
put together even a short statement from
someone in a position of authority to
address the biggest concern that people
have around the games you know they knew
that this event was going to happen well
in advance for perhaps you know yeah a
year plus now and the allegations that
have been leveled at Ubisoft for its
toxic work environment the encouragement
of abuses of power the enablement of the
pieces of power as well as the actual
abuses of power themselves whether
they're physical sexual mentor whatever
it may be
those have been coming out for quite a
few weeks now and the fact that they
haven't been able to pivot to address
this speaks to a an unwillingness to
kind of support the people who have been
affected which they should be doing and
also to support the people who are still
at the studio it's not that hard and
people and it should be thought of as
considerate and smart and thoughtful to
do that right now especially as you're
showcasing the games that the thousands
of tens of thousands of you know people
at Ubisoft are working on for the first
time it would have been the ideal moment
for leadership to come out and say we
are using your talents your abilities
your smarts your experience to give the
company a future and in return this is
what we're going to do to make sure that
all of that is protected and you feel
like we're looking after you and we're
giving you a safe comfortable working
environment they didn't do that and the
excuse that we recorded in advance so we
weren't able to pivot is frankly
unacceptable like it's ridiculous yeah I
feel like if you can get I know I know
that it's you know we're not gonna hang
on this for too long because at the same
time these people have worked on these
like these thousands of people have
worked on these games and want to talk
about them and celebrate those two but
like you had a pre-recorded Phil Spencer
presumably toiling in from his living
room
the rest of the presentation was slick
it was done in a studio presumably under
social distancing regulations was it I
it's very very frustrating you know they
had a pre-show you could have addressed
it there something more than just a
tweet Michael yeah
well I guess what I like y'all put it
pretty clearly and I think that all of
us here stand by what Tam and Lucy said
and I also think that my perception is
that putting out that tweet is less than
the bare minimum I think there's a lot
of people with eyes on this event and of
course we want to celebrate those games
but leadership has at Ubisoft has the
existing leadership has come and said
that we are going to make drastic
changes we're going to try and promote a
much better more inclusive safer work
environment that would have been the
bare minimum to come out in front and
like maybe you've come all would be
upfront before it is show any games and
say look we understand what's going on
here and then we are going we are
working extra hard to just reiterate
that message that you've already said
it's already been stated that they are
political trying to build a much more
inclusive and safer work environment do
that at the front of the presentation
because there are a lot of people
watching and maybe not everyone is privy
to the things that have been happening
within Ubisoft structure and the pieces
of power that have taken place in there
but I also think it's a disservice to
avoid it altogether when everyone's
watching so I mean it's I don't think
it's a good look and people who aren't
privy to it may still not know about
what's going on and I think it like
Tam's Tam and Lucy said it's a
disservice to a lot of the people who
are like putting in a lot of hard work
on these games at Ubisoft who or they're
to work put in passion into these things
where some leadership positions have
been abusing their positions so I think
you know moving forward I want to see
this confronted in a much stronger way
rather than just platitudes and I mean
platitudes could have been could have
been the bare minimum for this
presentation we didn't even get that but
I mean I think I'll I'll for me I'll
leave it at that yeah okay I'm gonna
kind of move the conversation along now
I think we've all definitely set our
piece and hoping to see some meaningful
change and statement from Ubisoft coming
forward and like I said these games are
made by thousands of people we want to
be able to talk about their work and not
have it completely overshadowed by the
atrocities that have been happening
within Ubisoft so with that as a
graceful segue as I'm gonna get let's
talk about you before words a little
different for them in terms of
presentation they have been kind of I
feel experimenting with this format a
little bit over time they did you know
obviously the pre-show and that you know
set sort of this their other titles the
ones that they're not really focusing on
right now so you had TrackMania little
things from hype escape and updates for
the division and Tom Clancy then I mean
the actual show itself kicked off with
watchdogs and I'm very I'm honestly
quite conflicted about the use of Martin
niemoller 'he's first they came speech
honestly was not expecting and I
remember when I was interviewing Ubisoft
developers last year for watchdogs
Legion they kind of said you know it's a
political game but please don't ask us
compress it and it feels like they've
really just doubled down on this being a
political game and I think calling in
niemöller
is and that in all the connotations that
that very powerful poem holds is you
know quite the statement to make Michael
I know you've had a lot of hands-on time
with watchdogs again
Legion and you've spoken and clean
talking about it what your is that is
that very much within the game itself
it's not just the marketing I do at
least based on so I played watchdogs
Legion for four hours earlier this week
to do all my preview coverage you can
check it out on gamespot comm but here
I'll try and contextualize it with what
was shown during the presentation
because I do feel like there's a bit of
a
connect with how it's being presented or
at least what you saw in the
presentation and what's actually in the
game that's not to say like the game was
like this hardcore revolutionary thing
and it tries to evoke some of that and I
explore that a little bit and what I
wrote but it was like man they're
they're messin they're playing with
playing with fire which i think is in on
one-on-one case I do think it's bold
that they are trying to evoke that and
have this game that tries to
contextualize uprising and rebellion in
a very real sense especially in 2020
this games coming out this year and it
touches on a lot of different things
that we see out in the streets this game
is built around authoritarian state
taking over London it's about police
brutality and it's about people
collective action and revolution and you
know if you're going to evoke a lot of
language and imagery of revolution in a
very real way then it's an expectation
that you also do right by it and I think
the the the way it was presented during
the you saw forward like with that with
that video was a little tone deaf
especially also in the context of what I
played with watchdogs Legion so yeah
it's it's not great but as far as the
game itself I do think that watchdogs
Legion is I think it has a lot of
potential to be powerful to send a
strong message whether or not it follows
through I mean I only played for hours
so I didn't get that much of the story
but I do have concerns in certain areas
I don't know how deep how deep you all
want to go and go into it or if you have
any specific questions I can get into in
some pretty deep detail if y'all want
yeah I mean I was gonna say
so obviously watchdogs wanted to you
have the one core character who you're
controlling and following that storyline
through this one you can kind of see
when they recruit anyone within London
and the way that they were shown in this
presentation it was very much kind of
selecting the right person for the job
and honestly when they were talking
about the different roles you know that
had the construction guy you had the guy
who actually work for Albion I was
getting big Hitman vibes would you say
that's why I Michael I said exactly that
in my preview so I yeah I did a gameplay
focus preview and that is the impression
I got not in terms of I mean so that you
when you recruit a bunch of people you
can choose who you want to play as at
any moment and everyone has their own
occupations which means they also have
their own outfits and costumes you can
outfit them in like normal clothes but
you've also switched to what their
specific occupation is and in my preview
one mission took place in a construction
zone and I had a construction worker so
I walked right in where security guards
is roaming around and I'm there and my
my hardhat my safety suit I'm just
walking around like nothing's going on
so I I infiltrated this this
construction site to save a hostage or
whatever and it gave big hitman vibes
because I'm just like walking around
avoiding detection not trying to get too
close
trying to take out guards where it's
necessary without being seen and it has
an element of silliness to it I guess
because just like general video game
nonsense and it was really fun I think
gameplay wise it's it's pretty strong
and yeah I like you're seeing in the
footage here the construction worker can
also call in a carrier drone and he got
on top of it while remotely controlling
it to fly up to different places so
there's a lot of different tools at play
that do remind me of hitman and yeah you
can outfit yourself with a spider bot
and not a little bunch of non-lethal
weapons so there's there's so many ways
to approach the missions now I don't
expect the missions to be designed in
such a deliberate detailed fashion as a
hitman game but I think a lot of a lot
of them the the gameplay beats that it's
hitting do remind me of my experience
with the hitman games yeah one thing I
want to yeah one thing I want to kind of
like talk about or just touch upon is
the kind of
the political angle again just a bit I
am you've written a great piece that's
on the side now about it being
definitely political but one of the
interesting things and is something that
you write in there is it was a history
of evoking political context and
socio-political realities but then you
know also saying that it's not a
political game and their games do not
make any political statements and I
guess the thing that I want to say is
like we've kind of just set by and
allowed it to happen
in previous years have been like well
you know it's been a thing that we've
talked about briefly and they will move
on but I think the in watching the
trailer for this maybe it's because it
hit home for me as well I'm sure as it
did for Lucy and various other people
who around the UK that I feel like I'm
more empowered now and I feel like it's
more necessary to place greater scrutiny
on what you know is being said in this
game so I guess my my message is like
Ubisoft has previously kind of held this
foot against the door and not let anyone
open the discussion about is this
political in a way that we want to I
don't think we can do that now given the
nature of the game and how closely it
reflects real current environments it's
it's out in our interest to you know
push through that door and break it down
and have that discussion that's one of
the things I'm interested in doing and
like hiam discusses like moments from
watchdogs to where you know the main
character has this kind of unique
discussion with another character and
it's all and watchdogs to being one of
the games that is pretty cool in the
franchise and they're giving it away for
free to anyone who watched it later so
it's worth playing just to see stuff
like that but like the the reason that
discussion was important was because
it's two black characters that are
speaking to each other and they're able
to relate to their circumstances so I
guess my question for Hire me is like do
you feel like this opportunity to do
that when the game is also about playing
anyone and everything that's a that's a
very good question and I think it's
going to rely on so in the
and in play as anyone you have to
recruit certain characters and there are
missions tied to their recruitment
process and I think that's where it's
going to have to show because there
there are certain characters to recruit
that are specific specifically baked-in
and so I expect to get story tidbits out
of that so one example is that like I
had to recruit an Albion officer and he
has a friend who needs medication and
the healthcare system is broken so we
can't get it there the the gangs that
run the street are selling at a very
high price so he can't get it there so I
need to help him get those meds so there
was like a little bit a small piece of
storytelling that spoke to a broken
healthcare system now as it relates to
race and how because obviously character
appearance is going to be randomly
generated I don't know how it's going to
handle it if at all and that's
definitely something that everyone
should be have a keen eye on is that how
are they going to have those
storytelling moments as it relates to
race because systems of oppression and a
police state and police brutality is
inseparable from racial issues like
racism drives a lot of those elements
that this game is trying to touch on so
if it doesn't go all in on that in some
capacity I do think it will fall short
in that regard and one thing I'll note
is it's kind of a small little line in
one of the main story missions so Nigel
Cass is the rut he runs Albie on which
is the private military corporation
that's overtaken London and he says a
small line where quote-unquote illegals
are ruining families and then like if
you if you're gonna inject that into the
narrative in some capacity you can't
just use that as set dressing like if
you have a character say that then
there's needs to be something that
pushes back on that message to make it
clear whether this game stands and the
fact that the systems of oppression also
are intertwined to race so I don't know
if it's I don't know if it's gonna come
out of like the characters themselves
like it
watchdogs too but I I would hope that
the characters that surround this
narrative some of those some of the more
baked in narrative pieces they need that
they need to touch on that and they
needs to touch on the the inherence lady
the fact that race and capitalism are
inherently tied to the systems of
oppression that watchdogs Legion is
trying to portray absolutely before we
move on from watchdogs I just want to
touch briefly on the setting of London
itself ubisoft also obviously prides
themselves on kind of these recreations
of worlds and honestly feeling homesick
for London right now did about you Tom
yeah very much so yeah it looks really
good I'm very Michael if you ever been
to London I haven't but I did in
watchdogs Legion but I also I did a
little bit a little jewelry search of
like the locations and stuff so I saw a
big bang clock tower what went down the
the tames Riverwalk I saw the London Eye
I was in Southern District I liberated
that district oh really it's not south
work by the way all the characters they
gave me the the lowdown on how to
pronounce certain things so i liberated
Southard for y'all so you can head down
there it's all good the police presence
is is minimal at least it wasn't my demo
but I think that if we're gonna talk
about like the London location I think
it looks looks great
it's it's very much a cyberpunk sort of
vibe because it's it's a tech tech
dystopia at this point in the game so
it's visually pleasing but there's a lot
of imagery of like you see a lot of
electronic signs saying Albie on police
officers obey the law or you gonna get
your ass beat and things like that or
like or you'll have messages hacked by
dead SEC and it'll say like power to the
people or things like that
some some of that imagery there but
overall like I mean it's same thing when
watchdogs to went to the Bay Area a
we're in the Bay Area and it was really
while to drive around there by a that's
where the GameSpot office is or a No
you're gonna get that same vibe here
when you're playing watchdogs Legion if
you've ever been to London and if you've
been homesick and if you want to
liberate your your home city then by all
means do that so yeah but you know we'll
see where this where this narrative
takes us we only play for hours and this
is a very big game but it's important to
keep a keep your your thumb keep your
third eye open and be skeptical and be
critical of the things even if you enjoy
them so I'll say that mm-hmm I imagine
we'll see more there's gonna be another
user forward we're not entirely sure
when but the game launches October 29th
at least one current gen consoles they
didn't really have a date for next-gen
but they have confirmed that it will be
supported by xbox smart delivery seeing
it on Series X and there's some strange
verbage around if you have it on like I
think they're also the growing pains of
going between a generation where you can
now get obviously get a discrete Xbox
but for PlayStation you know you can get
the disk drive free PlayStation 5 so
there's some verbage that if you have
the ps4 disc as long as that disk is in
PS 5 you're gonna have to be careful I
guess if you buy it on disk but then get
the disc free ps4 ps4 but I get a
discrete PS 5 this is an interesting
little wrinkle that I didn't really see
coming but I guess we'll find out more
when the game launches later this year
and hopefully we'll get a date for next
gen I'm gonna rattle through some of the
other titles before we hit on things
like hyper scape and Assassin's Creed so
brawl Halla
coming to iOS and Android August 16th
little hints for my magic Tom Clancy's
elite squad the elite Russell's more
like because they keep showing another I
just want to say for the record
it'd be soft if you are not gonna
announce a splinter cell game stop
pointing Sam Fisher in things like it is
absurd and the only thing that is gonna
happen is you're gonna rustle us we're
gonna get upset and gamers will remember
this
so you're famous noise stop playing Sam
Fisher in things if you're not gonna
pull out a new splinter cell game eva
tell us is a splinter cell or let that
guy go ridiculous
let him be at rest all right and then
moving on to hype escape so open beta on
PC right now 52 battle pass the free
Michael I know you're playing a bunch
you excited you gonna dive in again more
yeah I'm definitely gonna give it
another another round or two or a couple
more rounds
I mean battle Royales there's a lot of
them out there and I got to play during
the technical test and all that and so I
got to experience it a little bit
beforehand and one thing I'll say is
that it does a lot of different and new
things that other battles have not so
I'll give it credit for that so it's
such as feeling like an unreal
tournament or a quake it's very much an
arena shooter in many ways and the way
that it plays from the combat especially
because you're jumping around you're
double jumping you're hopping from
rooftops and you've doing rocket jumps
and you're trying to line up Splash
Damage and you're trying to line up
shots against fast-moving enemies that
are also double jumping and there's a
bunch of abilities that you pick up so
there's no it's not a hero shooter
because there are characters that you
can choose to have different voice lines
that have different aesthetics but you
also pick up powers throughout the map
so you're diluting guns and you're
looting powers themselves such as a
cloaking ability or a super high jump
where you turn into a hamster ball and
putting up a wall and things like that
so there's a lot of wild possibilities
in this game so it's definitely trying
some new things and I think now that
it's an open beta and it's also free to
play I think it's it's worth giving a
shot I think you know if you've been
burned down on battle royale though I
don't know if it's going to like
convince you otherwise but if you are
looking for something a little bit
fresher in the battle royale space I do
think hyper escape is worth giving a
shot maybe it'll it'll be for you I
think that it has some things to improve
on but there are exciting elements I
think my favorite part is the end game
in which the once you make it to the
last few squads instead of being the
last squad to survive a crown
will spawn into the map and if you can
hold on to the crown for forty-five
seconds then your team will win the
match regardless of how many players are
remaining it reminds me of oddball from
halo so you need to hold on to it and
but the thing is like all the enemies
will know your location they will be
pinged to your location so you better
you better square up and get ready for
some wild firefights cuz yeah and shout
out to Khalif adams and blessing out a
yo-yo junior there are my squad mates
when we were playing and we held it down
for the Crown's so yeah we got that game
play on gamespot if you want to keep
that thanks you because you know you and
I play quite a lot of apex are playing a
lot of war zone right now
do I need to install it are we pivoting
I mean maybe I will see how it goes the
open beta is out there right now so I I
definitely gonna have a I think we
should jump in and try it at least know
where it stands amongst the landscape of
battle royale games and my pleasure is
the way we play though we do stuff like
we'll start with one game and seemingly
move across every more you play a game
in all you know kind of like sweet until
we we finished our play sessions so
we'll see if if if kind of like it can
slot in around something else like I
can't imagine us like maybe swapping our
apex for a bit to play a hype escape
just because apex is kind of like we
play like across you know internet
connections with people in the UK and
that kind of stuff as well so and it's
not the best at handling that
transatlantic lag so I feel like there's
an opportunity for hype escape to sneak
in and maybe like push push apex out of
the way if it's got it going and sadly
it's not available on consoles just yet
I don't believe the open figure is
available on the consoles this year so I
think if apex still got has a little bit
of time in it to kind of maybe grip us
again put some extra content in there
but I'm definitely willing to give it a
try you are oh definitely I'm very
interested in - I know it's it's not
necessarily here oh shoot - but there
are a lot of it that remind me of
overwatch I think in terms of abilities
even though that's a 66 but I'm
intrigued
I think I'll probably spend this week
doing that alright let's move on to
Assassin's Creed Valhalla so we got a
little kind of 10 15 minute presentation
within you before word itself and then
after we go to post show which was
actually a pretty chunky bit of gameplay
a 30 minute gameplay demo narrated I
personally I was a little wary when they
started that presentation because they
were just showing the the lovely blur
pre-rendered CGI trailer again but
seeing it in action I'm genuinely like
I'm a big Assassin's Creed fund and I am
I love the fact that they've taken this
series in this direction
my big concern I think when I saw this
was yeah I'm loving all of the changes
to more full-on game play full-on combat
you know dual wielding different
mix-and-match weapons you can also there
was if there was a moment where you had
a bow and arrow and you were aiming at
someone who was running towards you and
he started zigzagging out of the way
which play a lot of open-world games
where you have a bow and arrow I don't
think I've ever seen that before that
was really cool
one thing that I was concerned about was
obviously the origins the roots of
Assassin's Creed the core tenets of that
franchise are stealth and so I think
certainly within Odyssey and origins you
kind of lost focus on the on that but
I'm intrigued to see how it's gonna work
for Valhalla I can't decide if I'm gonna
be my usual stealth Archer or if I'm
actually gonna go in dual wields blazing
I guess Michael will be your um
what was your take on the gameplay that
we saw well first I want to give a shout
out to Jordan remai who previewed it for
us one of our one of our top lads here
at GameSpot so he actually got hands-on
with it so he'll have more details to
share if you want to beat that but from
what I've seen and from what I've read
when I was helping edit his feature is
you know I'm I'm ready for some
open-world nonsense and I think that the
combat is kind of it looks like it's
leaning more into sort of the style that
I'm looking for but also its this is
just such a it looks like a world that I
want to explore so I'm I'm down to get
into some nonsense to kind of explore
this you know this European lush
European world where you know there's
Vikings and stuff like that so but I
mean I've also had my fair share of
Assassin's Creed games at this point I
did replay origins recently so you know
I I'm not expecting something
revolutionary but there are a lot seems
like there are a lot of dope mechanics
at play here and I think Jordan also
mentioned the different ways that you
travel so there's going to be easier to
get around different places with fast
traveling and some of the narrative
elements seem really interesting as how
it ties to the the present day
Assassin's Creed sort of narrative line
I guess and the fact that you can switch
a AV or was it a voir between male and
female at any time and the fact that
that has narrative implications that's I
think I think now that I think about it
that's the thing that's going to hook me
like I'm gonna get in some open-world
nonsense but I also want to get some get
something meaty out of it as well like
if you're gonna take this this this
Viking aesthetic this Viking setting I
don't want it just to just be about
brutalizing my enemies or anything like
that I want one a little bit more chew
on and I'm getting a sense of that yeah
I think the way that they were
discussing it is you know when they were
table viously Vikings well-known
throughout history for pillaging and
raiding but they were trying to humanize
them a little bit by saying you know
they left Norway there wasn't really
much there they came to England because
of all the abundant resources the lush
greenery the castles and stuff it's
trying to humanize that process so I'm
interested to see how that works because
I guess throughout history we've always
learned the Vikings are just this very
harsh people but it also seems like
because you're building your your kind
of home it's not called a homestead is
your settlement and you know gathering
and I'm intrigued to see how much
that'll play into the game
ploop tam what are your feelings on that
yeah I'm I'm really excited to have that
kind of that's the one thing that I was
kind of missing in and a lot of the
recent Assassin's Creed games like
investing in a place a little more like
they've done a great job of showing off
places but like a c2 Brotherhood that
kind of feeling of building up your own
and kind of like town was it called
Monterey Johnny or something like that
I can remember what your own own
settlement thing was called year but
like that
and it makes perfect sense for a game
like this given the setup we've you know
we have these Vikings trying to find a
new home establishing that so I'm really
excited about that element of it and
seeing how it feeds I think that that's
what was exciting about the a situ
element or like what's remembered great
about is there was so much of the main
gameplay that fed into that settlement
building in the original ac2 series kind
of stuff and so I'm excited to see how
the the kind of like menial open-world
gameplay has an impact on that because
that's something that I've been really
feeling with open-world games where you
have all these tasks and and kind of
like checklist stuff but it doesn't
really result in anything major this is
a great way to go back to that classic
Assassin's Creed 2 feeling of everything
you do even if it seems mean you in the
moment and and not particularly
satisfying you go back to your
settlement and you'll be able to make it
satisfying by investing in a place and
building it up and seeing your your
progression and growth which is
important in a game where you know the
RPG mechanics don't make it super easy
to feel the immediate growth you often
have to spend hours and hours and hours
before you feel like alright I'm getting
somewhere my characters powerful and I
have these weapons and armor and by
having a place and a people that you can
visibly see growing and and making life
better for them could be an interesting
way to to kind of alleviate some of that
that kind of grind the other thing I'm
really excited about is the rocks
shout-out to rock stacking rocks so I'm
going for rocks and rocks MVP 2020 and
the rock says let's do this I genuinely
gonna say you were very
recruiting cats oh yeah the cat thing is
that the cat thing is like a side side
thing that I'm gonna be writing at least
5,000 words on and maybe four videos
damn just put cats in your game and
you're gonna get you're gonna get free
coverage from Tam and easy before we
move on from Assassin's Creed a couple
more things I wanted to pick up on I
like the kind of gathering your army and
storming fortresses which is a very
different kind of take I guess in
Assassin's Creed where you typically go
in you are the one man or woman army and
you sort of try and stealth kill
everyone but this one I was getting kind
of shadow of war vibes
you know gathering an army and raining
destruction down on the stronghold it
I'm very excited about and also big fan
of the fact that on your ship you will
have crew mates who not only will sing
songs but they will have little stories
that they're gonna tell again there's
nice little humanizing aspects of
Assassin's Creed games which I'm a very
big fan of games coming out November
17th ps4 PS 5 Xbox one Xbox series x pc
and stadia which they're all in fact
people playing stadia it would seem I'm
interested to see how it's gonna run
honestly I feel like stay D has been
quite quiet recently alright and then
they ended the show with I always feel
really bad when a game leaks especially
one as high-profile as Far Cry six you
know you cut that image the I think the
storefront for Far Cry six leaked and
it's got Giancarlo Esposito best known
as Gus fring from Breaking Bad I am
honestly like I know that they shut off
the the lovely I assume blast Studios
fancy CGI trailer but there are more
details about this game that are kind of
coming out Alessandro Valeri on our site
I've got a pre-brief on it it's written
some stuff up if you want to read more
but it sounds really like honesty
interesting and I fully buy into the
theory that this kid is vast it's got
the same scar over its right eyebrow I'm
into it I've got my tinfoil hair ready
but the lowdown kind of like they didn't
really go into too much detail in this
trailer is obviously Giancarlo is the
president
he's a dictators named Anton Castillo of
the island of Yarra which is kind of a
place held back in time by his
dictatorship he has his son here Diego
and you don't ask Diego which I thought
that that was what was going to be
leading up to you actually plays a
character called Danny Rojas you can
play as a male or a female and you're
working to overthrow the dictatorship
and it has you know things that they
introduced in [ __ ] are four or five you
know the fangs for hire and the one that
I picked up on is the fact that there is
a little wiener dog called chorizo which
I'm very excited about we love it
Michael you talked earlier about some
open world madness far cry is pretty
much the franchise for that are you
excited to head to the island of Yarra
before I get excited about any open
world nonsense when it comes to far cry
6 I think that there are a lot of things
that need to be addressed about it and
it's setting because it is again it's
it's kind of like watchdogs Legion this
is almost a 18 for Ubisoft at this point
is like they're saying we're not we are
now embracing the political messages
behind these games and that very much
comes through in the imagery that is in
this trailer and also comes through in
alesandro's interview that you can catch
on GameSpot so like I said with
watchdogs Legion is that if you are
going to evoke these messages then you
got to do right and buy them and I don't
like listen video games in general have
had generally I actually I would say
almost across the board poor
representation of Latin ex people you
know it's often times they are relegated
to being like these like unhinged or
gang members like in wash dogs 2 or just
playing into stereotypes right but here
it's it's about the people of Yarra
taking the revolution in its own country
so it's not going to have this
this [ __ ] asks a white Savior
complex at least and I hope it follows
through on that but you know these it's
hard to do these things right in a video
game setting especially when the main
verb is to shoot and kill I would assume
since this is a Far Cry game so it's
it's it's very touchy and especially
when you are trying this is basically
Cuba that's my impression I'm getting
that Yara is a parallel to Cuba so it's
going to evoke a lot of themes of again
authoritarianism and revolution and
uprising and what it takes what what
these things actually mean what are the
systems of oppression and how do they
affect the people and how do the people
react to it so they're they're gonna be
messing with some pretty heavy themes
and far cry doesn't have a great track
record when it comes to those things but
you know I think this pivot towards
embracing the political side of things
and having the devs upfront about the
fact that they are trying to go for this
revolutionary message it does give me
some semblance of hope but I don't think
you can blame anyone who is skeptical
about whether or not it's going to land
right so I'll leave it at that when it
comes to that but I personally I like as
a brown person and as what they would
say a Latino of Asia
I would hope that you know that this is
this is gonna give fair representation
when it comes to a lot next people
absolutely I wanted to ask you so you
just have to putting out three very
meaty open-world games in very quick
succession you know you've got watchdogs
in October followed by assassins in
November and then Far Cry is coming out
in February that's a lot of games for
not a long amount of time which one do
you think you're gonna prioritize and do
you think this is maybe a mistake for
them to put three of them so close
together I don't know if it's a mistake
I think they for for our audience it
might feel like there's going to be
inevitable fatigue around it I think
that they've had this in the past where
you know they were
complaints about all of the resource
games starting to bleed together and
have this like open world checklist map
feature style thing and I think to some
extent that is still somewhat present
but I think each of the games are now
doing something distinct enough that
they have you know the ability to stand
out more more like broadly speaking to
the you know people outside of the
hardcore audience that we speak to
there's probably going to be situations
where someone picks and you know and
it's like I'm gonna I'm a far cry person
I like far cry because I like shooters
and I'm gonna get into that or as you
know there are you know countless
Assassin's Creed fans who know that once
they get that Assassin's Creed that's
them for like six months or maybe and
then watchdogs is still for for as much
as we think about a watchdog is still a
franchise in its infancy and I feel like
the awareness around it feels more than
it is because of opposition in the
industry like I don't know that many
people or I'll say that I don't think
people speak of watchdogs on the same
playing field as you know Assassin's
Creed and even far cry there was a games
over long lineage was and what shows is
kind of the new kid on the block so I
feel like people might just kind of like
pick it up as a curio or something like
oh this looks interesting
I think there's the smallest thing
they've done is is make the game in
London because that's a huge kind of
unique selling point for it as well now
and I feel like there will be fatigue
but I don't necessarily think it's a
mistake for myself personally I think it
is the same as with you guys I imagine
like I will be playing all of them I
don't think I will
I'm inclined to like play all of them in
succession like I might space one of
them out and pour it later and if I had
to do that it would probably be far cryo
which thankfully is coming out a few
months after anyway but I'm I'm excited
for each one and I think they all have
something unique to offer to kind of
compel me to play all of them even if
they are quite similar in a lot of
regards
all right we're just about gonna wrap up
here Michael what are your final
thoughts on the very first Ubisoft
forward they got they got some some
interesting games lined up I think
gameplay wise it's it's pretty much a I
wouldn't say guarantee but I would bet
on them being fun to play Ubisoft is
very good at building fascinating open
worlds with a ton of stuff to do I think
like watchdogs Legion I'm so the thing
about watchdogs Legion is like I'm more
excited now for it than I was before
even though I'm even more skeptical
about how it's gonna handle its themes
because its gameplay I think is
fascinating and I do like that they are
embracing its themes so I think that now
like at least now that we know what
these games are with far cry 6 watchdogs
Legion Sasa's Creed to a lesser extent
but now that we know that they are going
all in on these themes now is the time
for these games to show us that they
mean it and you know I'm not gonna
discount these games before they're out
but I am going to be keeping a sharp eye
when I play these games about how it's
doing its storytelling look how it
pieces its narrative together so with
that I will say that I am looking
forward to these games and I'm looking
forward to dissecting what they have to
say and also the open-world hijinks that
comes with it Sam what about you yeah I
think I call a lot of what I am said
there I think watchdogs looks
interesting Assassin's Creed looks great
watch out that's great as well and I'm
excited to get back into a Far Cry game
especially with this vast conspiracy
surrounding it but I I think Himes right
like we we need to pay more put those
games under more scrutiny of narrative
Lee speaking they are inviting us to do
so and we should absolutely do that I
think each of those games has like I
said previously a distinct gameplay loop
now hopefully but the most interesting
aspects of them are the narrative and
the characterization and the rocks and
cats in Assassin's Creed Valhalla
while always also say is that before a
first you know
attempt at Ubisoft forward I think it
went down pretty well obviously there's
the one thing that we wish they could
have handled better and we will continue
to hold them accountable for that stuff
but as far as Nintendo Direct clones go
it's pretty good and if they're going to
do it again do not mention Sam Fisher
unless you're mentioning the game just
to reiterate stop - behave yourself or
just let it go relax
leaning Sam Fisher alone we already lost
yeah we already lost snake we cannot
lose another stealth icon and we won't
serve I and let it happen
in this way let him go let him hang out
with snake just leave the sneaky boys
alone some kind of not gonna reiterate
those points believe the sneaky boys
alone that will be another you bizarre
forward in the future um I hope that
we're gonna see more of you know gods
and monsters Beyond Good and Evil 2 is a
little curious just kind of skull and
bones gods I don't even remember the
last time we heard anything from Skull
and Bones I think I interviewed them
like you know three four years ago at
this point about that game
fingers crossed they're doing alright
and yeah we all obviously be covering
those peoples our forwards as they
happen just like we will be covering the
Xbox series X inside Xbox on July 23rd
as well as all the other huge game
announcements hands-on etc etc from
across this summer so make sure to stay
tuned to gain sort of calm youtoo.com
slash GameSpot on behalf of myself
Michael and Tam thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next time
blood-borne
even save much there